foreign
[Music]
Arthur so nice to have you here thanks
for joining thank you Sam it's great to
be with you I've been looking forward to
this me too I feel like we've been
looking forward to meeting and it's
we've been warming up for this for a
long time with so many friends in common
we have a lot of friends in common I
have read your prior work from strength
to strength excellent book recommended
to me by Peter attia people may know him
as Dr Peter attia a good friend
proud Texan also now
where all the cool kids live for Austin
Texas where all the cool kids are and I
have
more questions than we will have time
but I'm hoping to really explore broadly
and I wanted to start with something
that I thought would
peek the interest of many people
listening and that is the reverse bucket
list
is this something you still do and what
does it entail yeah the reverse bucket
list is something I do oh boy do I ever
do it and it took me too long to figure
this one out
when I was
50. I'm 59 years old when I was 50 I
found my bucket list from when I was 40.
you know it was a classic thing and on
my birthday I would make a list of my
desires and my ambitions and I would
kind of imagine myself visualize myself
consuming or experiencing these things
and it would fire me up and make me well
kind of feel like a loser quite frankly
because it was it was it was lowering my
sense of satisfaction I subsequently
found out and I looked at that list from
when I was 40. and I checked everything
off that list and I was less happy oh no
at 50 than it was a 40. I'm a social
scientist so I thought to myself
obviously I'm doing something wrong what
am I doing wrong
and basically this is the problem this
is a neurophysiological problem and a
psychological problem all rolled into
one handy package
I was making the mistake of thinking
that my satisfaction would come by
having more
and the truth of the matter is that
lasting and stable satisfaction which
doesn't wear off in like a minute
comes when you understand that your
satisfaction is your halves divided by
your wants halves divided by ones that's
the model so you know let's go slow down
because I know people watching and like
let me write that down halves divided by
ones you can increase your satisfaction
temporarily and inefficiently by having
more
permanently and securely by wanting less
I thought to myself hmm
so what does that mean and the answer to
that what does that mean is I need a
reverse bucket list not that I'm not
going to get nice things in my life but
like I'm going to be consciously
detached from them by going through the
exercise of writing them down and
Crossing them out
so on my birthday now my 59th birthday a
couple of months ago I wrote down all my
ridiculous Ambitions and desires of
money or whatever power ambition
admiration all these things that I want
from other people that we all want
because we're human and mother nature
wires us to to accumulate the rewards
that'll help us survive and pass on our
genes I got it I know how evolutionary
psychology works
and I know that these things are going
to occur to me as natural goals but I do
not want to be owned by them I want to
manage them I don't want them to be like
phantasms in my limbic system managing
me I want to move the experience of
these Ambitions to my prefrontal cortex
which is my executive manager the bumper
of tissue right behind the my forehead
and the way that you do that is by
looking at each one of these Ambitions
and saying maybe I get it and maybe I
don't
but I'm going to cross it out as an
attachment and I'm telling you Tim I'm
free and so you find that to work it
works it works it works it does not
because you don't care about it but
because you're not attached to it in the
same way you've made the decision to
have it not be a a rootless desire a
ghost in your head you've made it into
something that you will consciously
manage by literally experiencing that
ambition in a different part of your
brain
so you go through this exercise so you
write down whatever it is receive such
and such an honor right sells so many
copies of book X right whatever these
are all the stuff that guys like you and
me do right and then you have 37 inch
arms and in your case possibly you're
incredibly fit I'm not hitting on you
I'm just saying I aspire to you're a
beautiful man
well we go to the same stylist for our
haircuts but I would say we will maybe
get to like self-care and physical
practice later you go through this
exercise you write those things down you
cross them out yeah
in a sort of idol worship sleight of
hand move right and
then following that I'm curious when
there is if there is the spark of this
desire whatever it might be do you have
self-talk or something that acts as an
interrupt I keep the list you keep the I
keep the list and I go back and I look
at the list just like I would look at my
bucket list later every six months or
every year every 10 years whatever it
happens to be I go back and look at my
reverse bucket list and say am I living
up to this am I truly conscious am I
living up to not being attached am I
practicing the Detachment that I
committed myself to and the truth is
usually yeah kinda I mean the Phantasm
will be back it will be flying around in
your head again but but you brought it
to your prefrontal cortex for a reason
and your prefrontal cortex is an adult
and will govern the children but
sometimes you have to remind yourself
remember look I mean you're an adult
here and you look back on you say and
it's funny actually it's pretty amusing
when you look at it and you say oh I
can't believe that thing is bugging me
again but you're not governed by it in
the same way you know what I actually
put on my list I was reading you know
when and it's just to just for clarity
so it's okay to have the goal and to
have it as a Target and plan for it
let's say selling X number of copies but
not to have that Hungry Ghost attachment
to it it's nothing more than an
intention
intention is fine but attachment is bad
you know and this is what the Dalai Lama
talks about too he talks about intention
without attachment there's a word in
sailing the rum line in Spanish which is
a lot more common in normal everyday
speech and what it means is it's the
it's the intention of your Voyage you
have to have that even though you know
it's not you're not going to be true to
it because if you don't know you're just
gonna be going in circles you'll you
know you'll just be like I don't know
I've been out to sea for a long time who
knows where I am you know it'll be like
one of your vacations it's like I don't
know where I am I'm just like doing
nothing man which is it can be
therapeutically important but it's
actually not the way that you get from
Europe to the Americas you need a
location in your your end point on the
GPS but if you're super attached to it
then you're gonna freak out when
something throws you off furthermore
you're not going to recognize the fact
that it is the voyage itself that is the
adventure of life not actually reaching
the particular destination whether it's
the original one or one that turns out
to be better or worse or wherever you
wind up and that that's the way you got
to live your life so it's intention
without attachment now there's another
thing that I was thinking about this
year because
um ticknot Han died you know the great
Vietnamese Buddhist monk and I wrote his
obituary in the Washington Post actually
wow it was it was a really interesting
experience because I talked about all
what he's taught all of us and take not
Han said and it always had an impact on
me but I reflected on upon his death
that one of the greatest attachments
that people have in modern life is to
their views and opinions
that's a real attachment it can be as as
dangerous as your attachment to money or
power why because people treat their
their opinions as if they were gold
they're Jewels you know get between me
and my political opinions man I'll
cancel you I'll get you fired I'll
denounce you on social media who knows
maybe I'll be violent I mean life is
crazy these days yeah and so I looked at
it I thought am I weighed down by
attachment to My Views to my political
views so I wrote down five of my
strongest political views
and I crossed them out
this was after writing the obituary yeah
it was on my reverse Bucket List when I
turned 59.
and I said look it's not that I don't
have these views I just don't have these
the attachment to these views look man I
need more friends
and strong political opinions is not
going to get me there it's not going to
get me there love is going to get me
there tolerance is going to get me there
a sense of curiosity about other people
is going to get me there and strong
political opinions is going to put me in
the wrong direction so man dead
the attachment dead
so maybe this is a little too granular
but I'm curious take not hot this is a
legendary figure
I would be very intimidated by
the the task of writing an obituary for
such a person I've read numbers of his
books been very influenced by his
thinking how do you go about deciding
what goes into an obituary for someone
like that or for anyone for that matter
but in this particular case
the Germans talk about doing a something
called a Fest shrift it's a word that
means kind of this in encomium it's a
celebration of the work of somebody and
which always start when you do one of
these things it's you know typical sort
of European intellectual deal is you
look at the things that they said and
did that had the most impact
and it was most meaningful to them in
the same way now I didn't know tick not
Han I've worked very closely with the
Dalai Lama in the in the Tibetan
Buddhist tradition but the theravada
Buddhist tradition I've never penetrated
personally and so I didn't know Tech not
Han but I do know the the things that he
said and taught that really changed the
way that westerners think and so that's
what I wanted to talk about now what did
he do that changed
therawada Buddhism I'm not a there about
a Buddhist I don't I'm not equipped to
write that but I can talk about the way
he changed me as a Catholic I can talk
about how he changed me as
a public policy person because I was
reading technot Han when I was running a
think tank in Washington DC how he
influenced me as a happiness professor
at Harvard that's the stuff that I
really wanted to focus on
and what that was the idea of attachment
and detachment
that was the the idea of the illusion of
individuality I mean these are Concepts
that people didn't think about
he also was really behind the whole
mindfulness revolution in the west he
starts off the miracle of mindfulness
that famous book big bestseller with
this simple description of washing the
dishes and he says when you're washing
the dishes you should be thinking about
washing the dishes because if you don't
think about washing the dishes you're
not really there washing the dishes are
you and he persuades you with this kind
of hypnotic prose to remember that if
you don't think about washing the dishes
but you're thinking about doing
something at work tomorrow or you're
thinking about something that happened
yesterday that you're living in the
future of the past and you've missed
your life yeah or if you're thinking
about eating the juicy Peach which is a
story may not have been in that book
that I remember him telling but it was
paired with the washing of the dishes he
said if you're thinking about the peach
while you're washing the dishes when
you're eating the peach you'll probably
be thinking of something else exactly
right and then what you're doing is
you're while you're doing this you're
planning for a future existence that's
better than now and when you reach it it
will be a Phantasm as well it will be
nothing more than a mythical past while
you're thinking about a new future that
doesn't quite exist and you've missed
your whole life how did he change you or
influence you as a Catholic
it's an interesting
and the Dalai Lama too by the way I mean
a lot of Buddhist thinking has been
incredibly helpful to me to
to understand exactly what I'm what I'm
trying to do as a person when I'm
centering myself in prayer
so for example
Catholics traditional Catholics they
generally pray was called the rosary and
the rosary is a set of beads that you
pray repetitive prayers it's about a
thousand-year-old Catholic meditation I
do it every day
and I noticed that I was having a hard
time
focusing I was having a hard time
understanding what I was trying to do
for myself for this offering I didn't
know how to make it fruitful in its way
I didn't know exactly what the point was
and studying the work of technot Han and
also studying at the Dalai Lama's
Monastery in dharamsala India sitting in
meditation and studying meditation
techniques with the Tibetan Buddhist
monks I actually learned what I was
supposed to be doing as a Catholic
praying my rosary how I actually could
center my prayer and make it deeply
worshipful in a meaningful way and
perhaps God wanted me to learn that from
my Buddhist sisters and brothers
this is going to be
adjacent to this conversation this topic
but I'm curious do you believe that if
we can always cut this but I'm very
curious do you believe that direct
Transmission in some of these lines
which is very important in certain
schools of we could call it mindfulness
but that that is
a real phenomenon or at least I suppose
it's undeniably important in the
tradition but the idea that sitting with
someone in meditation
with them
there are teachings that are sort of
directly transmitted
what is your thought on that if you have
I don't know the answer to that I do
know that you can deeply be in communion
with somebody and really intimately and
and my wife Esther and I we actually we
teach young couples that are engaged she
teaches the theological part I I teach
the social science you know because I'm
just a you know I'm a total wonk and
what we do tell them is that according
to the best science and and our
experience and common sense that one of
the most intimate things that you can do
with your partner or spouse pray
together
super intimate I know couples that have
been married for 25 years that will have
sex together but won't pray together
because it's too embarrassing to pray
together because praying together is
just too intimate they don't know how to
do it it's embarrassing to them imagine
you'll get naked in front of somebody
else but you won't pray in front of them
and that's because it's such a deeply
intimate thing okay so when you cross
the boundary of the greatest intimacy
with another person there's going to be
some transmission there's going to be
something and it's going to the idea of
direct transmission Rings true to me
because of the nature and intensity of
the intimacy that comes from that
experience so we're gonna take a hard
left for a second and we're gonna come
back to the through line which I am
tracking
because it's just what is top of mind
for me and then we're going to come back
to possible mystical slash semi-mystical
experiences in Mexico so I'm giving an
idea all right I can't wait my head I
get to go to Mexico and have mystical
experience the imitation is now formal
but first for those who are not watching
this video I mean you are incredibly
physically fit and I know that you have
some very deliberate consistent
practices including weight training and
so on blood occlusion training are you
still using cuffs I do yeah and I
recommend it for anybody over 40. could
you explain what this is and why you
recommend it so occlusion training what
it effectively does is it it's not a
tourniquet but what it is it's a band
around your arms and or legs so that
when you're lifting you actually will
get a much greater as you know in the
vernacular the burn from resistance
training with lower weight now the
reason I recommend this very strongly is
because the research suggests that it's
very good for both strength and
hypertrophy at lower weight levels so it
saves your joints but gives you results
and that's what you need to do when
you're over 40. save the joints yep and
I I really strongly encourage people to
check this out I've done some of it yeah
and to say that it increases the burn or
the pump is certainly true you gotta
love pain you yeah I would exactly I
would say start conservative because you
you might feel weak dialing back the
weights but just wait it hurts it really
does and you then but then you learn to
love the pain yeah and you can travel
with there are cuffs you can travel with
I have them I carry them with me all the
time I'm on the road 48 weeks a year is
there a particular type that you use
yeah well I don't actually remember the
brand but they're actually they use
velcro and they're about two inches
thick so it's too thick and actually
can't get the kind of occlusion that I
really want so experiment with you know
what works with you know the size and
shape of your biceps and triceps and
then and then learn how to use them and
then make them Tighter and then and then
get in touch with the pain and they're
easy to travel with do your homework and
start conservative Kelly starred a very
famous performance coach and PT is a
friend has been on the show many times
introduced me to that yeah it's amazing
and he had a very similar argument which
is effectively he doesn't say this but I
would say like you were kind of as old
as your joints and connective tissue
feel I mean there's certainly a
cognitive component and this is a really
elegant way right to preserve or build
muscle mass without I learned this from
my friends Stefano who started mind pump
with
with his partners and mind pump yeah you
know Fitness and culture podcast and
that's what I've been listening to it
for years and years
and he taught me how to do it he
actually is gives me training tips and
good ideas and that was great it's been
very helpful and by the way you know
when I was a younger man you know when I
was in my 30s what I figured you know
like what's my goal with Fitness and the
answer is to still be lifting when I'm
80. to still be able to why because we
know of all the health benefits from it
but but the truth is that physical
fitness for me is a way to manage my
negative affect it's actually a
happiness technique for me it doesn't
make me happier it makes me less unhappy
that's what physical fitness will do
it'll buy you less on happiness and so I
manage my negative effect that way and I
know when I'm 80 I'm going to need to
manage my negative affects so I don't
want to hurt myself so I would go to the
gym when I was 35 or 40 years old and I
would I would go to these iron gyms
Whenever Wherever I was traveling and I
would find the oldest dude yeah the old
guy who's still lifting heavy things and
I would go up to him and say can I ask
your advice and they always want to give
you advice you know the 76 year old guy
who's he's like don't bench press it
restricts your range of movement and
that's going to hurt you're going to get
impingement injuries along the way so
that's why as you get older you should
actually press with dumbbells and and
then do higher rep to get volume do
higher reps with lower weight Etc and
just the sensible stuff but but it's
actually been incredibly helpful for me
to not get hurt and stay in the gym 100
percent
all right so naturally from the sublime
to the ridiculous well maybe ridiculous
maybe not so not for me it's not that's
for sure could you please describe your
experience I think it was as a teenager
was it as a teenager in Mexico oh yeah
it was not out in the woods with a
shaman in ayahuasca
when I was 15 I was on a on a band trip
I used to be a musician and I started as
a kid I was a real serious musician and
I wound up being a professional musician
from when I was 19 until I was 31.
French horn yeah I was a French horn
player classical French horn player all
the way through my 20s I didn't go to
college until I was 30 but it's my Gap
decade and and when I was I needed one
of those yeah too late and when I was 15
years old I was on this trip with a
group with a you know with a profession
not a professional it was a like an
amateur concert band but you know doing
a tour through Mexico and we were doing
a lot of Tourism and one of the tourist
activities was to go to the shrine of
Guadalupe in Mexico City now this is a
famous place for Catholics because it's
one of the great pilgrimage sites of the
world in Catholic teaching this is where
the Spanish explorers came to Mexico and
having a horrible time you know because
their marketing was all goofed up for
the Catholic church I mean convert or
die it's not a very compelling it
turns out you know and racist and you
know everything that you possibly could
want what happens then is this weirdly
miraculous thing for Catholics and and
and fellow Travelers I mean just it was
a mystical experience so there was a
peasant Man by the name of Juan Diego
who was outside on a hill outside of
Mexico City and and hasn't sees an
apparition of the Blessed Virgin Mary
so he on his Poncho is imprinted the
Blessed Virgin Mary's image on his tilma
he takes it back is a textile yeah it's
like well it's sort of a poncho it's the
tilma is what they would wear and it was
based on a fabric made out of
Cactus actually and so and it's it's
beautiful imprint in color almost
everybody has seen the Blessed Virgin
Mary of Guadalupe on this and if you
Google it the version of Guadalupe and
you see you say oh I've seen that a
million times because it's in every
Latino church and she's the for the
Catholic Church she's the patroness of
all the Americas including the United
States I mean this is a big deal for the
church so the bishop sees it you know
they take the Telma they display the
tilma in public and for the first time
they start getting converts in the next
nine years seven million people convert
to the Catholic church now why
there's worldly explanation there's
Divine explanations for it here's a
worldly explanation that's pretty
compelling Our Lady of Guadalupe is not
white
she's not Spanish she's a mestitha she's
a woman of mixed race now we don't
realize how incredibly subversive that
is how unbelievably culturally
transgressive that would have been the
Blessed Virgin Mary is not
not white what are you talking about no
no no she's us she's us she's every
person in the world she loves you she
loves me and she's one of us because
she's in all of us and that was this
weird message that nobody really would
have thought of at the time or so Laura
goes and that's why people started
saying ah oh this actually is for me
because she actually looks like me crazy
so anyway so I'm in this church in
Mexico City the shrine of Guadalupe and
you know I'm looking at the tilmas just
sitting up there and I'm thinking this
is boring
but then I noticed she was looking at me
she was looking at me now to be sure I
didn't realize that you can look at
Elvis on velvet and the eyes will follow
you right okay fair is fair
but I couldn't get it out of my head I
couldn't get it out of my head so
worldly or Divine or mystical or not
reasonable people can disagree but I
couldn't get the image out of my head I
couldn't
and I realized I needed more in my life
I needed a deeper sense of the
metaphysical in my life I needed the
Transcendent in my life
and every time I thought of it I thought
of that image and so I became Catholic
at 16 years old and I've been a Catholic
man ever since and did you have a family
history of Catholicism
I know I grew up in a Christian family
so I had a little bit of wiring but I
literally knew no Catholics it's just
this thing okay and you know my parents
were like ah adolescent Rebellion I
guess it's better than drugs it is
better than everyone
but and the point is a lot of people
watching us some are traditionally
religious and some are spiritual and
some are not but the whole point is
we have a sense that there's something
else we have a sense that there's
something deeper let something in your
life take you to the deeper Place
something needs to take you by the hand
to the deeper place there's a lot of
research that suggests this is the case
don't try to go to the deeper place to
find it randomly on your own let someone
take you now that Insight is it's
ambiguous
but once people start to say I'm ready
to be taken to a deeper a deeper place a
more Transcendent state that person that
entity will appear
we may come back to that thank you and I
do think that
many different paths touch corners of
the same thing is my impression which
which we may not have time for in this
conversation but
to be continued and the reason I'm
asking about this experience for those
people who are wondering how this ties
into maybe the headline of the podcast
is because I
want to better understand the influences
and experiences that have shaped you
right and you're like perception
operators and your thinking so another
would be you've had multiple wake-up
calls in your life and as you described
you didn't exactly have the linear path
to Harvard Prof that people might have
envisioned right yeah
oh Exeter Harvard McKinsey
I actually applied to Harvard for
graduate school and they're like no it
took two weeks for them to to reject my
part of it is at the time I was 31 I was
a College Dropout I had a degree from a
correspondent school I was a French horn
player these are not the core
demographics of your typical Harvard
graduate student and so
yeah I got rejected which suggests by
the way Tim that our standards for
faculty today are lower than 10 for our
students but be that as it may maybe
maybe I'm skeptical in your case I'd
like to talk about your dad yeah so who
was your father what was he like and
how did his life end
my dad was a mathematician he had a PhD
in biostatistics
he was a lifelong college professor most
of it at a small Christian College in
Seattle called Seattle Pacific
University he was born to missionary
parents
Evangelical missionary parents he was
born in the Navajo Nation in in New
Mexico
where my grandfather ran a Mission
School actually and then my grandfather
went on to become the dean of a very
famous college outside Chicago called
Wheaton College
where all of our family members had gone
my aunt went there in the 40s and dated
Billy Graham in college yeah yeah so and
then my dad you know went on to another
Christian College to the college where
he ultimately taught and he was just
absolutely in love
with the beauty of mathematics
as kids you know my mother was an artist
my mother's a painter my dad was a
mathematician and you know in around the
dinner table we would talk about art we
would talk about math those are the
things my father would pose math
problems to us he would say okay okay
boys me and my brother imagine all of
the all of the integers between 1 and
100 one two three four Okay add them all
together what's the result
and we're like I don't know I need a
piece of paper say no you don't think in
another way think of another way the
solution by the way is one plus a
hundred equals 101 and 2 plus 99 equals
101 and 3 plus 98 equals 101 and there
are 51 of those which makes 51
combinations of 101. got it and so
that's 5050. that's what we would do
that's that's what my father would do
you're like Dad I'm just trying to eat
my macaroni I know so I eat my macaroni
cheese and they always say something
like see isn't that beautiful isn't that
beautiful isn't that evidence of God
that's what he or your mom would say
that's what he would say my dad would
say the Elegance my dad believed not
that what we know is what we should pay
attention to but the to Marvel at what
we can do and still not know anything so
my father would you explain this had a
big impact on me that there's two kinds
of problems in life there's complicated
problems and there's complex problems
it's a mathematical difference but the
technique doesn't matter complicated
problems are all the things you can
solve with computational horsepower and
and Tech complex problems are super easy
to understand but you can never solve
them like who's gonna win between the
Patriots and the Dolphins I know what
winning looks like it's more points on
the scoreboard but I have no idea and
that's why it's beautiful to watch the
game and you don't want to simulate it
on a computer because it'll be
inaccurate
love is complex a jet engine is
complicated a cat is complex a toaster
is complicated and he said two kinds of
problems and this he said as a basic
math problem the reason that we're
always unsatisfied in life is because we
we have complex problems we want love
and all we have is complicated solutions
that the world is offering us like you
know computers and the internet and
social media and blah blah blah blah and
you'll never be satisfied because it's
the wrong kind of solution for the wrong
kind of problem
so that seems like a tremendously
valuable Insight yeah you describe your
father
as a happy man no my father was a gloomy
man and no doubt that had a lot to do
with genetics because 50 of our our
emotional Baseline is genetic we know
this from identical twin studies where
twins are born and separated at Birth
into separate family this is not an
experiment that social scientists have
done because that would be horribly
unethical but three identical strangers
shows how that turns out yeah
brutal doc oh yeah that's a great
documentary it is great but fifty
percent of your Baseline mood your
tendency toward you know ebullience or
gloominess is
sitting in your in your DNA and the
result of that is you need this is the
reason Tim that I came to the happiness
field because I saw my grandfather who
was
a wonderful man and gloomy and my father
who was brilliant and and a lovely
person and an excellent ethical kind man
who was gloomy and I said no more man no
more I'm gonna live on the other 50
percent
I am not going to be governed by that 50
that that made my father an unhappy man
and so he died young 66 you know I mean
he had cancer and they gave him
10 or 15 years or more
and he died in two and as a statistician
he explained it he was a biostatistician
by his graduate degree and I said that
it's terrible luck and he said look
there's got to be people on that side of
the curve too
but he had a good sense of humor but the
whole point was he wasn't prepared to
fight for life
because he
he didn't have the the hygiene for his
own happiness
and that
example set me on the path to learn
about this and to share these ideas and
it has transformed my life I'm grateful
to my father and I will be for the rest
of my life for the example that he gave
me in the lesson he taught me even
through his unhappiness hi everyone Tim
here part of the interruption just a
quick announcement the recording studio
had a small glitch so the audio for the
next two or so minutes is not perfect
but we correct it quickly please bear
with us thank you for understanding and
now back to the conversation what were
some decisions you made or things you
began doing or stopped doing after your
father's death
I started exercising there is a little
vanity to it but not that much the whole
point of the matter is this is one of
the single best ways to manage your
negative affect is to be in the gym for
an hour a day yeah and there's a it's a
bit dated probably but there's a book
called spark which also goes into sort
of a lot of like bdnf and a lot of the
circuitry and biochemical reasons for
exercise for this explicit purpose when
I'm working with students I put them
through a battery of tests to look at
whether the bigger challenge in their
life is happiness or unhappiness the
world is really scarce in the
definitions that it gives us and there's
a big mistake that almost everybody
makes about happiness which is not a lot
of mistakes number one that it's the
absence of unhappiness number two that
it's a feeling both of those are wrong
number three is that we can get it so
we can approach happiness
but we can't get there because we
actually need unhappiness and
unhappiness and happiness are not
opposites and can coexist so there's a
lot to yeah there's lots of unpack so to
begin with happiness and unhappiness in
terms of moods are largely processed in
different hemispheres of the brain a lot
of neuroscientists believe that unhappy
cognitions and emotions are largely
dominated by activity in the right side
of the brain and the way that we know
this there's a terrific neuroscientist
at the University of Wisconsin Richard
Davidson
and he's done work that shows that that
the left side of the musculature on your
face is more active when you're unhappy
when you're experiencing negative
emotions anger fear disgust sadness
and it's actually funny when you have
when my kids were little I would notice
that
you know when they fall down you get a
moment where you don't know what's going
to happen next are they going to laugh
and keep playing are they gonna you're
gonna get the water works right and the
way the tell on that because it's
usually five or six seconds because the
the wiring in the brain is actually not
complete it's a work in progress so one
of the tests that I administered my
students
and I put in my new book as a matter of
fact because it's so important for me
and for understanding ourselves that's
called a positive affect negative affect
series panis p-a-n-a-s it's on my
website and it's easy to find and I
didn't create it it's been
psychometrically validated a bunch of
times it's a great tests and what it
does is it helps you figure out if
you're high positive
High negative or low positive low
negative and there's four combinations
it's a two by two Matrix you can be a
high positive affect person and a high
negative affect person that's a high
affect person who's got a lot of strong
moods about everything that's the mad
scientist that's the mad scientist
profile that's me I'm at the 85th
percentile and happy affect and I'm at
the 85th percentile and negative effects
so the highs are high on the low right
so I don't have a happiness problem I
have an unhappiness problem this is what
it comes down another it's not a problem
because unhappiness is really important
you won't be happy if you get rid of
your unhappiness because you got to be
fully Alive to get happier but you do
need to manage yourself
some people are really high positive and
really low negative those are the
cheerleaders those people can't stay in
the gym why because they don't feel
better when they go to the gym because
their negative affect is already in the
cellar the third is high negative and
more positive that's the poet and nobody
wants to be a poet but the truth is that
the part of the rainbow lateral
prefrontal cortex is highly active for
people who are sad and people who are
creative that's the reason when I say
pull it you don't think about somebody
who's skipping down the street
French cafe you know thinking nihilistic
thoughts and writing poetry so that's
the poetic disposition and the last is
low low so you could be perfectly happy
or unhappy but you have low affect
levels that's called the judge the sober
judge I wish it were otherwise but I
would put high confidence that I am
right down the Beret wearing way how
would you advise someone and I just
won't apply to everybody listening but
just by way of
a working example what does someone do
with what are their options for how to
act upon that okay so that if you know
that you're a poet this is an affect
level it doesn't mean that you're
cosmically happy or unhappy it just
means that you're these this is your
natural disposition oh right and so this
is important right so it also means that
you need to manage two lovers you need
to manage your happiness levels up and
you need to manage your unhappiness
levels not to zero there's nothing wrong
with unhappiness you need to you need to
mute them you need to you don't need to
numb them you need to manage them and
could you and I may have already missed
the plot but just Define those two
because I think a lot of people myself
may be included would think if you
remove unhappiness by default since it's
unhappiness they seem to be antonyms so
you remove one you have more than the
other so how should we think about these
yeah yeah that's a very good question
and and by the way the answer is not
obvious as a matter of fact
psychologists until about 50 years ago
really believe that unhappiness was the
was the absence of happiness
but it's not true because we actually
find that they're the basic negative and
positive emotions are coming from
different parts of the limbic system and
can coexist I see so if you're thinking
about it you can think about it then
sort of neuroanatomically as opposed to
semantically with the words yeah yeah
not to dumb it down too hard but it's
like if your left hand performed X types
of tasks and your right hand performs Y
type of tasks it's like okay you can
sort of decide what ratio right you're
aiming for and your negative emotions
are much more intense than your positive
emotions this has evolved to keep you
alive positive emotions are kind of nice
to have negative emotions are signals or
alarms that something might kill you you
know a sweet smile from somebody across
the room is very pleasant but a frowning
face might be somebody who wants to
murder you and so therefore we've
evolved to pay attention this is called
the negativity bias that we have we also
have mixed states that we go through all
day long you ask people in surveys what
they're feeling at any given moment so
you'll you'll say you know in five
minute increments what are you feeling
positive or negative you'll find that
about 90 of the time people can tell
tell you how they're feeling in 40 of
the time for the average person it's
really pure positive emotions at a low
level it's your idol it's most of the
time it's good life's okay it's kind of
sunny today whatever whatever all good
about
sixteen percent of the time is pure
negative emotion and that usually means
something's happening that you don't
like now 33 percent of the time you've
got both and usually the way that this
looks in people's lives is that you're
in your positive Idol but something's
intruding so there's something bugging
you that you don't always remember you
know you know we go through life and you
know on a certain day it's like yeah
it's all good oh yeah that thing and
then you go back to kind of going back
to your positive violence oh yeah that
thing you know that thing and so that's
the mixed state like Twitter yeah
totally and by the way I mean it's an
unhappiness machine you mean X yeah
sorry exactly that's right a big black
ax I mean it's like X it's it's so
appropriate you know so this is
important because we understand that
these are separable phenomena we need
both we need both these emotions but we
need to be able to manage our emotions
like pros and that's a lot of what I do
yeah so what are some options so I I go
through the penis end up poet there are
these two levers
what might be the process of thinking
through how to pull these levers in
different ways the happiness side is
what I spend a lot more time on because
it's just so interesting on how we can
pull the happiness lover it starts by
actually a good definition which is not
feelings feelings are evidence of
happiness and thank God happiness isn't
a feeling can you imagine going through
life chasing a feeling yeah that's awful
it's like she feels good do it or some
or or if it feels bad make it stop it's
a terrible life strategy happiness and
its feelings are associated with three
tangible phenomena in our lives that we
can actually understand manage enjoyment
satisfaction and meaning
those are the three things that we need
in balance and abundance think of these
as the macronutrients of Happiness the
protein carbohydrates and fat of
Happiness if you don't have protein and
carbohydrates and fat and balance and
abundance all kinds of weird things are
going to happen to you you're not going
to be as healthy as you should be and
you won't feel good same thing is true
you need to enjoy your life you need to
get satisfaction from your
accomplishments and you need to have a
deep sense of meaning and each one of
these is a big challenge when I meet
somebody through a series of of
structured questions I can figure out if
there's a problem along one of these
macronutrient dimensions and it turns
out that it's there's some very easy
interventions that we can make across
all three and I'll give you an example
the first one is enjoyment and people I
say do you enjoy your life they'll think
about their little pleasures I said
that's not it
pleasure is not a secret of Happiness
pleasure is the fast road to
obsessive compulsive activity and an
addiction
why because all pleasure is is a
phenomenon from the limbic system of
your brain saying do more of that thing
because you're more likely to survive
and pass on your genes if you get those
calories if you have that sex whatever
it happens to be
the way that you can actually turn that
into a source of happiness is by mixing
in two ingredients with your pleasure
people and memory
never do something that gives you
pleasure alone that's the rule of thumb
if you're doing it alone is a problem so
Anheuser-Busch does a beer ad they never
have in the beer ad a guy drinking in
his closet yeah a guy pounding a 12-pack
this is an apartment alone you know why
because that's that's pleasure and that
actually leads to addiction is
problematic they always have an ad of a
guy cracking a beer with his buddies
people and doing something he's going to
remember memory that's the secret to it
so I'll take a a survey of people's
habits now this is the reason that
pornography is a big problem right
you're not consuming it in public with
friends to make a memory for God's just
some sort of weird early that's a pretty
weird thing to do right and that's one
of the reasons and I mean it hits the
dopamine lever I mean they all are
neurophysiologically similar phenomena
they hit dopamine dopamine dopamine
dopamine over and over and over again
and they ruin your life because they
become addictive they become mono
maniacal and they're not the secret to
happiness if you're at three o'clock in
the morning in Vegas pulling the lever
on the slot machine by yourself I'm you
know that's not the secret of Happiness
to anybody I know and I've never heard
somebody say you know you know what
gives my life happiness
methamphetamine never been said right
and the reason for that is because these
are drugs people say drugs of abuse no
no these are drugs of pleasure let's not
lie about it they give you pleasure and
pleasure alone without memory is a
problem this is a very practical example
of how we can use the science and turn
it into a set of guideposts for our life
and so you have enjoyment which you
clarify
how would you
make satisfaction granular because I
think about satisfaction I'm like I
might conflate
being satisfied with doing say a large
project with some form of meaning I can
see how I might get my wires crossed so
but how should we think about these two
satisfaction is achieving something with
struggle it really is that project that
you're talking about which it will give
you meaning as well the project per se
can actually cross the boundaries across
the macronutrients just like a something
that you eat has one more than one
macronutrient but satisfaction per se is
doing something that takes effort and
expending the effort so if my graduate
students they they cheat to get an exam
in my class they'll get the grade but
they won't get the satisfaction the
satisfactionally comes from the pain
this is one of the paradoxes of life you
gotta you gotta suffer to get the
satisfaction you've got to defer the
gratification when somebody's on the
pleasure Mill by the way they also don't
get satisfaction from anything because
they can't defer the gratification
anymore these problems bleed into each
other so
one of the things that you find is that
people are who are very accomplished you
know the people you are good at
satisfaction because you can defer your
gratification and do long-term projects
your satisfaction guy the problem for
you and me and a lot of people are going
to watch your show because they want to
be better I mean nobody's watching the
show just for Giggles they're watching
the show funny enough
they're watching your show because they
want to be better in their lives and so
they're going to be good at inferring
their gratification and doing hard
things or just aspire to totally I mean
it's like I've read your books it's not
anything it's like it's interestingly
deceptive the four hour fill in the
blank the early books right it makes it
sound like it's a hack and it's easy no
no it's not no it's not the four hours
is hard is the point that those four
hours are gonna hurt and there's a lot
of front loading there's also hard work
without forethought and planning so
there is built into any of those books a
strategic deferral yeah for sure so
that's what brings satisfaction here's
the problem with satisfaction and this
goes back to where we started the
conversation
Mick Jagger saying I Can't Get No
Satisfaction that's wrong
you can't keep No Satisfaction that's
why you try and you try and you try and
you and there's a reason for that you
know neuroscientists talk about
homeostasis which is a phenomenon of
always going back
physically and emotionally to your
Baseline and there's a reason for that
because you need to go back to the
Baseline in your life so you can be
ready to react to the next set of
circumstances if emotionally you you're
going to be bummed out for the rest of
your life you'd become immobilized and
if you felt super happy when something
good happened you wouldn't be in the
hunt anymore Mother Nature wants you to
think that you're going to feel this
emotion for the rest of your life so
that you will either avoid one thing or
pursue something but she wants to fool
you and send you back again and again
and again have you never figured out man
if I get that car I'm gonna love it if I
move to California I'm going to enjoy
the sunshine for the rest of my life
turns out you get six months by the way
of enjoying weather but the taxes are
forever and that experience of never
learning is called the hit on it
treadmill and it's unbelievably painful
the way to solve that problem is haves
divided by once the way to get real
satisfaction is not having more but
wanting less and that's the reverse
bucket list Etc that's the the set of
habits habits that helps you dominate
that particular science and
short-circuit the loop that you're on
because of Mother Nature's plans for you
which are not really in your happiness
interest she doesn't care if you're
happy by the way no no yeah producing
progeny is not dependent on yeah DNA man
it's all survival to pass on your genes
and you know that's great for the
propagation of the species it's not good
for I don't know pursuing the Divine
path we are going to come back to
meeting I want to just take a sidebar on
reducing wants right for a second sure
and talk about exercises
that you've had your students do in your
classes and
I'm pulling this from memory so I may
not get the wording spot on but
identifying their Idols am I yeah
getting this right so if you could
expand on what that looks like yeah we
have a game I have a game show in my
class at Harvard called what's my idol
now this you can tell how old I am when
I was a really little kid there was a
game show on TV called What's My Line
yeah yeah sure your viewers can Google
it I'm sure there's some black and white
grainy footage of it or something from
you know when I was in the 70s
what's my idol is actually based on the
Insight of a you know a medieval
philosopher St Thomas Aquinas Theologian
but really a philosopher in the
neoplatonic tradition
Aquinas is responsible for introducing
Aristotle to the modern world up into
that point nobody read Aristotle it was
all Plato Aristotle's teacher
uh St Thomas Aquinas he said no no no
guys read this one this is the one right
and he interpreted Aristotle for the
modern world it was the same thing more
or less that Ava Rose was doing for the
Muslim world and the maimonides was
doing for the Jewish world because they
were coexisting in southern Spain and
this this intellectual soup that's hard
for us to understand today it was so
deep what was going on
so St Thomas Aquinas was an unbelievably
adroit social scientist he was also by
the way phenomenally impressive figure I
mean for people who aren't familiar just
go read the Wikipedia entry and a few
other things yeah yeah right and his
magisterial work was the Summa theologia
which is just and the way that he does
it by the way is just it's a master
class in the way that we should be
thinking about big topics today which is
by saying by starting the topic with the
best objection
like
here's the question here's the
supposition what's the best objection
here's how I meet that objection what's
the second best objection here's why I
made the object the whole book is
written this way it's unbelievable and
in the section on human happiness which
he pulls from Aristotle who claims
without any need for proof this is what
we all want whether we act that way or
not that there's four things that we do
that distract us from happiness now his
definition of happiness is is seeking
the Divine you know this is what we all
want what do you want the Divine do you
know that not necessarily
is it hard yeah and that's the reason we
don't actually act like we're pursuing
the Divine because you know pursuing God
or the Divine or you know the
metaphysical Singularity or exterior
Consciousness or what your thing is has
a lot of one-sided conversations and a
lot of inconvenient morality attached to
it so we take these Divinity substitutes
these are the idols Idols are biblically
in in mythology what Idols all have in
common is that they're god-like but
they're not God they're convenient
substitutes for God that's all an idol
is and Saint Thomas Aquinas says there's
four substitutes for God which we can
think of as the four substitutes for the
real secret to happiness they are money
power pleasure and fame now little
things change and when he said faith in
the action to say Fame you said honor
but that has a different connotation in
English you know I have a son who's a
special forces in the military and and
he serves With Honor that's not what
they mean honor means to be honored it's
Fame it's reputation it's the Admiral
creation of other people maybe it's
Instagram followers or something
ridiculous but it is something that we
want in the opinion of other people and
we see thirst after it and he says
everybody is motivated by one thing and
it'll even throw away comments like
communities they coalesce around an idol
is so true you know we're recording this
podcast in New York money baby you go to
a party in New York and everybody's like
how's your fund this year how you doing
this year and like how much does this
apartment cost it's all about money you
go to La what's the idol
well I'm not going to even call it honor
fam fame fame okay okay let's keep with
the quiz DC what's the idol power power
man is how close are you to the
president what Senator do you know right
Vegas
pleasure yeah right I mean communities
will coalesce around this but each one
of us has our Idol too so here's the
game you want to play sure let's play
the game
Okay so
the truth is none of us has all four
none of us is so vice-ridden we don't
have the energy or time to be serving
all four of these Idols I mean come on
life you underestimate me sir
but we all have one or two that really
animate us and we don't always know it
because we're not paying attention to it
now now aquinas's point and modern
psychology Bears all this out that as a
normal adult with a complicated life if
you know you're idle you will recognize
the thing that always leads you astray
and leads you to do the things that you
later regret because you were following
that Idol so it's very important to
figure out which Idol that is so that
you can manage it not that you'll make
it go away because you're human but you
can manage your idol okay so I start by
saying what's not your Idol
because of the four there's something
that you could ditch yeah Power
immediately I'll name one to start with
so that's why you're not a CEO I mean
you've got a company and you you know
you but you're not like trying to run a
corporation yeah there's a lot of things
that are
and I know a lot of people who are
power focused in a sense in one form or
another it just doesn't do you dislike
it you actively dislike power like
people having power over you and you
having power over others I don't dislike
it necessarily I mean I I think that
it's an inherent dynamic in particularly
chimpanzee politics but just in nature
in general well speaking of which let me
react to this phrase Tim Ferriss for
congress no there you go absolutely not
your answer is correct you are not
motivated by power it's the first way to
get rid of okay you got three left money
pleasure Fame you gotta Kick one out you
got to get rid of one what's the next
one to go I can get rid of fam easily I
think that there was a point in my life
where I sought a lot of social
validation but having seen the flip side
and the shadow elements of that it holds
well you got pretty famous young yeah so
you saw the dark side of that which is
what social scientists and even
neuroscientists will tell you with their
research is that Fame is really the only
of the idols that you can ever be happy
in spite of you know when Lady Gaga
tweeted Fame is prison and everybody
derided that I'm thinking that's deeply
Adept yeah that is a deeply clarifying
comment and by the way I mean you know
John Milton wrote that in in you know
the 17th century that it is the the idol
that we thirst after and sacrifice the
happiness of our days yeah for that and
you learn that by by experience not
because of disposition because you did
hunger after it and then experienced it
and you realize that it's a very very
very bitter fruit yeah there are a lot
of footnotes and a lot of fine print in
that
Faustian bargain okay so I my 46 year
old Tim Ferriss that's number two that
goes out the door I don't care in fact
if I could put the toothpaste back in
the toothpaste tube in numerous ways I
would do that right okay you got two
left and it's getting hot in here right
[Applause]
money and pleasure yeah wealth and
pleasure
money I can
in the hierarchy I can get rid of the
marginal utility of each additional
dollars it just makes no difference in
the things that I care about so a middle
class life wouldn't freak you out
no at this point I mean I'm not talking
about poverty I'm not talking about
getting not getting three squares I'm
talking about not having the the money
for the nice stuff that people think is
really wonderful to have the houses the
boats the cars I don't really buy that
you don't care yeah I don't I don't
really care and I care less and less
because also the more financial success
you have the more time you spend with
people who have even greater financial
success and I've seen no indication in
fact might even be a contra indication
that wealth
produces yeah the things I'm after and I
think there are significant adverse side
effects well there's a lot of research
that shows that there is a way to buy
happiness but it's not by buying stuff
it's by buying experiences it's by
buying time and by giving it away and
you already figured that one out yeah
quick example of that for me in the last
handful of years I owe Tim Urban a huge
thank you for his article tail end I
ended up booking most years depending on
my family's health and so on but
a family trip once a year that we can
look forward to for like six months and
have group chats about and so on and
then even today was was discussing a
boys trip with some of my closest
friends oh like six months from now
right and the ROI on those is huge but I
would say money I can get rid of money
so we found your idol yeah Jim Ferriss
likes to feel good I do yeah yeah and
again there's nothing wrong with feeling
good but for you we need to watch to
make sure that you're you're getting
enjoyment and that pleasure yeah and we
need to be very disciplined about
enjoyment not pleasure and I would also
add to this that I do think a pleasure
junkie for for certain things the
central the sexual being very high on
the list there's also I think a wrinkle
to this like the the sort of Mara
sitting on my shoulder if anybody goes
reference would be given a history of
depression right I fear it's opposite
right so I chase pleasure as hopefully
some of inoculation against Darkness so
there are many things contributing to
that yeah well pleasure tends to be
numbing
it does tend to be numbing of negative
emotion so people will pursue pleasure
because they're actually trying to it's
it's Fentanyl you know there's a reason
that there's nobody who enjoys Fentanyl
because it's not something you like I
want to go hang out with my buddies and
take Fentanyl and make a memory on the
country you're trying to eviscerate
memory you're trying to get rid of
memory with these types of things and so
numbing things tend to work that way and
I understand I mean you've actually had
you have a history of mood disorders in
your life and you don't want them you
don't want them back you don't want to
invite them back and so you do something
that feels like an inoculation from
those depths the key thing is that the
real insurance policy
is enjoyment satisfaction and purpose
that's the real insurance policy okay
and again because because it doesn't
eradicate the unhappiness the darkness
but it puts it into context such that
it's part of the
the quilt of your life and so it's just
one square in the quilt of your life and
not the whole blanket yeah so I want to
expand on this so this is thread
selfishly that I'd like to pull on I
will add maybe just one thought which is
much of the pleasure that I pursue is
not numbing it's actually a it's a
volume competition in the sense that if
I start to get feel like there are
Whispers of the potential of an onset of
a depressive episode or maybe it's the
ruminative thoughts and anxiety that
comes with that but let's just say those
are at a two out of 10 volume there's
fear because I worry that that is going
to spiral right and so I seek out
something on the positive side of The
Ledger or let me just say the pleasure
Side Of The Ledger right that is higher
volume yeah you're trying to knock
yourself out of a groove right it's like
overcoming a dread of deadness with
greater aliveness right now what's one
possible
strategy it could be a substitute
strategy for that that's why I'm here
doctor yes
so so and there are so right there are
meditation and prayer a seeking for the
divine
serious spiritual practice these are the
things that we'll actually do much the
same things but without the numbing and
without the danger because it's tricky
right I mean hitting the dopamine lever
has consequences sure hitting it hard
and often has you know desperate
consequences for it and we know none of
us needs problems in our lives we have
plenty of those already yeah totally so
so yes and let's just say spare meditate
prayer spare spare prayer the name of my
forthcoming Book Like a Prayer
meditation I can see the difference it's
easy for say a secular listener right to
consider right
what would you say to people who are
perhaps secular not necessarily militant
atheists right who I think recognizes I
do in some ways I am deeply just to
layer on my sins here envious of people
who have strong religious conviction I
recognize the value and from a at least
in the sort of monotheistic
judeo-christian Traditions I I don't
think I'm likely to join
one of the Bands
so I recognize we can go do some some
blood occlusion training and you can
just mostly have Rosemary together in
between sitting right in between reps
lay the prayer on thick
so what would you suggest to me or
someone who recognized the value I do
not have a counter argument yeah but I'm
not sure how to embrace that there are
alternatives so I I can tell he was a
Catholic that that's my thing but I can
tell he's a social scientist that it's
not the only thing that will actually
bring the same neurophysiological and
psychological benefits what we need is a
sense of the Transcendent that makes us
small that's what we need why because we
need perspective and peace I mean 10.
you're going to go through all this like
my podcast and you know it's my commute
my money and my friends and my mom and
my mimi it's so man it's just so it's
like watching the same episode every
single night of Better Call Saul yeah
well for the rest of your life it's like
having the seagulls from Finding Nemo in
your head yeah mine mine mine mine mine
I mean it's just it's the worst and so
you have to find a way to get peace what
we really need is to put ourselves in
perspective now most people are afraid
to be little are really afraid to be
insignificant perspective requires that
we see reality and we get smaller and we
stand in awe of the universe and what it
can bring there's lots of ways to do
that um
meditation practices are very good for
that prayer is very good for that
religion on most traditional
circumstances very good for that but
walking in nature without devices Before
Dawn for an hour is incredibly good for
that for all sorts of reasons and this
is extremely well validated in the
social science literature hellborn is
the timing on that well it's good
because you start the day that way and
it's the programming of it and by the
way the experience of seeing the sunrise
is incredibly awe-inspiring plus it's
quiet and cool yeah all pluses quiet and
cool for sure therefore you get just a
bigger bolus of you know the benefits
that you actually get from being in
contact with the Earth and being in
contact with nature Etc
another way to do this is to stand in
awe of human genius that's way outside
the realm of your experience so learn
about the fugues of Johann Sebastian
Bach read about his life your favorite
oh yeah and listen to a hundred of his
cantatas and learn how to analyze them I
mean your life will never be the same or
you know your neighbor and our mutual
friend Ryan holiday read the stoics read
the stoics I mean it's a quasi-religious
experience you will feel a deep
satisfaction at your littleness probably
for the first time in years as a matter
of fact there are many ways to get this
but you need to get small in front of
Bach in front of Epictetus in front of
God you need to get small is the whole
point I love that it's easy to remember
right get small right there
just to underscore that for myself I
mean a few things that have been helpful
right nature yes yes
studying
or could it take the form of listening
to say hardcore history and listening to
King Kings of Kings the Assyrians and
really widening the aperture of your
historic lens just to put the problems
of this week in perspective
and also the impermanence of Empires
like
maybe relevant these days this is a
moment in time and yeah yeah so going
back and realizing some of the most
powerful figures in the history of
humankind you will not recognize which
also I think for me has been very
relieving and also has taken a lot of
the
earlier fixation on money away because I
realize it's just ashes to ashes dust to
dust right like to quote the
Ecclesiastes that's right give me the
full name of Alexander the Great most
people can so rather than get fixed on
some vague notion of Legacy like let's
actually focus on other things the
getting small looking at the stars
honestly I did so much as a kid and I
lost it and have sort of reclaimed as
this thing
that can be used as such a tool for
zooming out and I have two friends Ed
cook is is one notable example who when
he thinks of his problems and
I'm gonna paraphrase this but he will
look at stars and sort of zoom out from
his neighborhood himself
to the planet to the solar system and
when he then returns back to laying on
the ground looking at the stars like the
problems that were plaguing you just do
not seem that's the point so significant
that's really the point it's not just a
question of minimizing your problems
it's also minimizing the scale of your
hopes and dreams and opportunities and
recognizing that
what really matters
you're in that to be sure but you're one
part of that it's okay yeah it's all
okay the grade is just okay and the bad
is okay too and you know that's so
deeply comforting and it leads to so
many improvements in mental health
I just don't know how you can put one
foot in front of the other without doing
something like this every day now people
often ask okay how do we get started how
do I get started read 15 minutes a day
pick up the brothers k
if you like fiction stop wasting your
time on trivialities go get the brothers
K why because it's a deeply
awe-inspiring experience about the human
condition and the absurdity of it it's
beautiful get the meditations of Marcus
Aurelius who by the way a world
historical figure because he was a Roman
Emperor nobody remembers that
practically a single thing that happened
as Roman Emperor we remember what was
written in his private diary that's wild
that's crazy last of the great Emperors
mostly because he was dumb enough to
leave his son in charge oops his waste
roll
like the story of of humankind also
speaking with I think I want to leave my
business to my kids what do you think
Tim you know there's a there's a long
conversation my kids are awesome I
wonder if I wonder if I can get them
into the happiness
Dad I know you're always beating us over
the head on this happiness business it's
not my path I roll
so I'm curious for you personally
having thought about this deeply having
tracked a lot of things also
what are some of the
best uses of money that you have found
personally what types of things are
there any concrete examples that you can
give yeah so we rolled through that fast
just a second ago but it turns out
there's a ton of research on this my my
colleague Mike Norton and my colleagues
Mike Dornan and Ashley Williams at the
Harvard Business School they've done
this exhaustive research on how to buy
happiness how do I have that's right
okay and it's not Mother Nature says get
more stuff why because satisfaction
comes from having more what's the
strategy for life more Mother Nature
tells you that she's she lies she lies
lies and lies and laughs at you that's
not the strategy you need to buy enough
but no possession will do anything
beyond bring you out of misery that's
the reason that the studies you know the
famous
economy and get in study from Princeton
shows that happiness flattens out after
seventy five thousand dollars a year and
you know Matt Killingsworth at Penn
actually re-ran the data and finds that
it's higher but it still flattens out
inflation adjusted but still inflation
adjusted or you know your results May
Vary or whatever it is but the whole
point is you just don't get happier and
happier and happier as Millions The
Reason by the way that we think that is
an illusion that comes from our
experience most people have less than
they perceive they need when they're
young
and the result of it is that they a lot
of people and a lot of people listening
to us they suffer a lack of you know
meeting some basic needs you know when I
was 19 to 25 I was too poor for six
years to go to the dentist for six years
no of course I don't think everyone a
day without cigarettes so I guess it was
priorities but but the point is that
when I was just a champion oh yeah man
yeah beard cigarettes Pizza you know I
was living on the I was living in
Washington Heights in those days and
when I was 25 I took a job in the
Barcelona Orchestra I moved to Barcelona
had benefits I had Benny's man and I
went to the dentist and he felt you know
seven cow or ten cavities and I felt a
lot better and I thought
money goes by happiness no no no no no
no money lowers unhappiness when you
move out of deprivation that's it and so
what happens is I made the mental link
between getting money and feeling better
and people do that and they chase that
feeling for the rest of their life they
actually because you're you're doing
sums in your head of well-being is
happiness and unhappiness and all that
you can't tell the difference when
you're just you know rolling through
your life and early on you felt a lot
better that's all you know when you had
more money and so
you want that feeling and you chase the
feeling you chase the high you chase the
early hits like drugs like any other
drugs in this way so that doesn't work
but there are three ways you can by
happiness according to willins and
Norton my colleagues at HBS you can
buy experiences this is critically
important because what do experiences
that where you buy happiness really have
in common you add money which is sort of
my pleasure but they're really important
parts are the people in the memory
people in memory people in memory are
always part of experiences okay now
sometimes you want to do things alone
but generally speaking the greatest
happiness comes because it enhances love
in your life the best way to improve
love in your life if you want your love
life with your partner to get better go
away together
go away together that's always the best
best way to do or stay home together but
turn off the phone in other words get an
experience with a person that's a great
way to spend money because it will
reliably unless you waste it do
something stupid like I'm gonna have a
bender in Vegas and and then you know
have you know get blackout drunk and sit
in front of the slot machine that's not
the secret
but you know being prudent
you can actually buy happiness through
experiences that's number one number two
I'm going to ask you for personal
examples but yes yeah
I'm serious yeah for sure buy time buy
time but use the time correctly you know
if you have the money and you're cutting
your lawn and you don't like cutting
your lawn
improve GDP hire a guy now a lot of
Americans don't like to do that because
they have this kind of this weird
reverse classes sense well let me tell
you there's a lot of people who are
making more money than you cutting Lawns
and running a guarding service spread
the love give somebody a job and then
use the time correctly don't Fritter
away your time scrolling social media in
the house in the air conditioning use
the time specifically for something
ideally with somebody doing something
that you enjoy and that will truly buy
happiness and last but not least give
your money away to somebody who needs it
who deserves it and a cause that truly
inspires you something you really really
believe in I've studied philanthropy
long before I studied happiness I was
you know an academic beavering away in
obscurity writing books on charity and
philanthropy and non-profit
organizations and and the reason I
initially got into happiness in the
first place besides you know wanting to
be happy was that I found that the more
people gave the happier they got
so we don't have to tread into these
Waters but I think it would be very
helpful for people and I'm very curious
I'm happy to reciprocate also yeah where
have you landed for where to give your
own money I give money to things that I
really care about that I think have an
impact on people's lives in a big way
and a lot of what I do is I give to
education to people who are at the
margins of society so I give a lot to
primary and secondary education
specifically to Catholic primary and
secondary education because I think it
is it's really really well done and it's
an option that a lot of people don't
have access to because it costs money so
a lot of what I do probably 75 percent
of what I give away and I give away 10
of my income good for you yeah because
you know it's it's not that hard to do
you just have to pay attention to it and
then there's structures you know so you
get a chance
or yeah I do think it was a tithe but I
really think of it as a privilege I
think of it a lot less as a duty and a
lot more as a privilege my wife and I we
just look forward to it and then you
know we have a process in our family of
you know should we give money to this
yesterday that usually we give something
kind of a big bolus one year and then in
the smaller gifts to things that are
ongoing sources of support that we
really believe in how do you decide what
to give to well we know the people we do
the work right so it's not just anybody
we get a letter in the mail when we
respond with a big check it's like huh
that seems worthy no we actually do the
work and part of it is because I teach
one of the classes I teach at Harvard is
on non-profit management and so I have a
you know kind of a strong background in
you know whether it's a reputable cause
and what to look for into measuring the
effectiveness of an organization so I do
the work I do the background work you
know I see what kind of overhead rates
that they're using how they're using
their money A lot has to do with if I
like the mission sometimes if it's going
to be a substantial amount of money I
get to know the people and the
organization and and it has to be
something that I think is going to
change people's lives for the better now
I've actually changed my view on this a
little bit because early on
you know we'd write a lot of little
checks lost and lost and lots of little
checks to Great organizations and then I
found that you can have a lot more
effect on your own well-being and again
this is kind of selfish but in your own
well-being by concentrating on turning
the whole dial in one person's life
that you can really so I mean really and
there's an old talmudic phrase from the
book of Sanhedrin that says in every man
is the whole world right in other words
turn the dial for one person who've
turned the dial for all of humanity
because it's really had an impact and I
remember telling my wife about that it's
like yeah I can finally got these data
that when you really help one person
instead of a little bit for a lot really
anonymously you can you can get all
these benefits she's like this is years
ago this is Maybe
20 years ago now and she's like
why don't we adopt a baby
and I'm like it's only a book man
but we did we actually did it was
totally life-changing totally but I mean
it's really for us so
so that's how you give you got to do the
work and think about it and put your
heart into it how did she come to the
adoption
my wife yeah how did she came to it
because I was saying you know you get a
lot more benefits When you turn the
whole dial on one person's life as
opposed to just you know throwing
dollars
yeah she's like no we should basically
like okay buddy you really really I mean
this is like I know you got this
interesting research you know fancy
social scientist guy let's see should we
put our money where our mouth and by the
way she had also been having dreams
about
a little girl who was abandoned
your dreams and dreams and dreams if
you're over to it can you tell me more
about your wife and how you guys met
because I know a little bit of the
background but how did that how did that
happen since I'm back on the playing
field you're back as a Playing Field
Time
one of the things that I teach my
students at HBS
is that I would never
invest in The Firm of an entrepreneur
who's unwilling to give her or his heart
away because as the single most risky
entrepreneurial thing that you can do
putting every bit of capital at risk if
you're not willing to give your heart
away I'm not gonna put my money in your
fund
now and that takes the form of risk man
loving someone wholeheartedly giving
your heart away okay giving your hard
way so and the reason I believe this is
because you know I've always had the
sense that part of the Journey of life
is just like getting in it yeah getting
in it and you know entrepreneurs talk a
lot about putting Capital risk and
talking about money how boring the real
capital of the Enterprise the startup of
Tim ferriss's life because this is the
ultimate Enterprise I mean the
Enterprise is not the podcast and the
books and the company and the that's not
it those are manifestations of Tim
Ferriss Inc of you yeah the Enterprise
is you and the currency of you is not
money it's love and happiness that's
your currency so how are we going to put
that at risk for explosive tectonic
inflecting Returns what are you gonna do
to put it at risk that's the question
right and the answers are really tricky
but the one answer that's not right is
don't put it at risk don't put it at
risk right so I I'm with you now there
are
Myriad ways that if you were to sort of
take off your flak jacket and just walk
into the
oncoming traffic with like emotional
oncoming traffic with someone who you've
been on a dating app who you meet within
five minutes and they're cuckoo bananas
that could turn out poorly of course
that's just Vegas right that's not
entrepreneurship that's just gambling
right so how well first I want to hear
your story yeah so this gets back to the
issue at hand and and the reason I I did
that little Prelude is because I don't
want anybody to think that my screws are
too loose right I mean that's not not my
goal yeah my goal is not I'm not it's
Insanity so okay
I trust my case insane insane man on the
podcast deeply unbalanced guest joins
Tim Ferriss so when I was 24 years old I
was on a concert tour and I was making
my living as a classical French horn
player I was on a concert tour in the
burgundy region of France now going from
town to town playing concerts
and I was staying at this
school I don't know it's just where we
were we were housed during this you know
we were going out from there and at the
same time there's a music festival going
on and there were musicians from all
over Europe that were studying at this
music festival and I was at this concert
playing at this very school and playing
you know playing my horn looking out in
the audience and there was this girl
smiling at me in the front row beautiful
girl smiling at me just gorgeous and I'm
you know I'm a red-blooded 24 year old
dude and I'm like obviously I'm gonna
make a mental note to go talk to her you
know so I go to talk to her later and I
find out two things number one she's not
French even though I was in France and
number two that she doesn't speak a
single word of English and it was hard
because you know where I was I was
trying to talk to her and you know
monosyllabic Grunts and the the
fruitless search for cognates and I said
are you single I mean this is like this
basic are you single and she says yes
I'm divorced I'm like I'm not down with
that but what she meant was I just broke
up with my boyfriend but she couldn't
come up with any Latin based words
besides divorce which actually comes
from a Latin to try to get me to
understand this point anyway so it was a
comedy of errors and we went out to
dinner and we went on some dates and I
left after a week and I went home and I
called my dad in Seattle I grew up in
Seattle I was living in New York at the
time I said Dad
I think I met the girl I'm gonna marry
and where was she from Barcelona
Barcelona
and he said great let's meet her and I
said I got problems problem number one
is that she doesn't live in the United
States problem number two she doesn't
speak a word of English problem number
three is that she
made me aware that she doesn't believe
in marriage because she thinks it's an
anachronistic institution and she's
never going to get married it's a hell
of a yeah it's a concept to communicate
in yeah tarzany's yeah yeah no no for
sure I mean we're together for a week
can we you know
you got there we got there and I
couldn't get out of my head it was like
Our Lady of Guadalupe kind of I thought
about it I thought about it we exchanged
letters and weirdly somehow it talked on
the phone she started taking English
classes I started studying Spanish who
knows what I'll see right I traveled to
Barcelona saw her she came to New York
and visited me just a little bit here
and there and what I didn't tell her is
that I had quit my job in New York and
I'd won an audition to be a member of
the symphony in Barcelona because I
wanted to go see if I could close that
deal if I could change her philosophy of
marriage
it took me two years but I closed the
deal and 32 years later we have three
adult kids and one grandson and
and I'm still in love so how did you end
up debate teaming that I'm just curious
like how did I just wore it out so you
know we were you know as I live in
Barcelona she was in love with me and so
she's not like
get out it's not like I was some weird
stalker she really was in love with me
right and and she wanted to be with me
but you know she nobody in her family
was married I mean this is not what you
do in Barcelona I didn't realize that
because I mean it sounds like a big
Catholic country it's a post-christian
country three percent of the population
of Barcelona ever goes to mass three
percent I never would have guessed
Denmark in the Mediterranean that's
incredible no idea yeah yeah nobody does
for sure I mean it but but you know it
has a long tradition and she comes from
a a hard red communist atheist family so
suffice it to say that our background is
a little bit different I mean I again
you know she was beautiful and smart and
funny and and I was in love yeah and
it's just
love will out love will out and it
finally at the end of two years
I just finally I said
I got that on one knee and I said are
you ready to change your mind she said
yes
all right so once again
envious showed its ugly head
and I have to admit my French horn game
very weak very weird turns out the first
one was the least of tight pants tight
pants big guns in those days six foot
two and 142 pounds my wife said that it
was like
hugging a tight sack of rocks
now she says it's like a loose leather
bag of ropes so you know I've made some
problems yeah yeah is that progress it
sounds like progress
maybe that should be on my dating
profile if you hug me I feel like maybe
not make sure that's a little too so
babies fighting under a blanket I don't
know I don't know
so and maybe you're so far removed that
this doesn't make sense to ask but what
advice also you're coming from a
different
orientation with the Catholicism and I I
assume may be wrongly but I imagine but
not hers right now she fully aboard the
fully aboard but that took
that took a long time wore it down a lot
of prefer
as they say this is one of those
problems that requires prayer and
fasting
so you prayed and she fasted and you're
like no food
it will put the rosaries on its wrist
all right thoughts on how to find a
partner yeah no I think about this an
awful lot because this is the number one
Topic in my science of Happiness class
at HBS that they want to know about can
I say it's got to be oh for sure for
sure absolutely because you know not
only is it something that we all want
that everybody wants it's something
that's getting harder yeah all the
traditional scaffolding is gone unless
you perhaps you're part of say a Jewish
Community where yeah that type of yenta
like matchmaking is a very esteemed yeah
but even then the modern world is
encroaching on that and you know if you
look at the comparison between in the
80s when I was in my 20s or the 90s when
you were in your 20s sorry I didn't mean
to shock you with that you know yeah I
know
it's much much much harder I have the
ring of Frodo so I'm not planning on
Aging anymore from this point far side
note you should look at photos with him
now in 20 years ago they're the same the
actor anyway yeah not me though I mean
when I was in the Barcelona Symphony I
had this hair it was a it was like a
great civilization it's like the locks
of Samson that was unbelievable and and
so you know then I start going bald and
getting more and more bald and my
brother my older brother he's very
judgmental about me he's funny he loves
me but he says you deserve it because of
the life you've LED
[Laughter]
it's just a lot of DHT man anyway
so what are the guard rails what are the
mistakes that we make you know what's
actually making it harder and there's a
lot of things that go into it you know
there's the fact that we're using Tech
where we would have used humans is
deeply problematic I mean the fact that
we have so much deal flow is making it
harder the Paradox of choice is a real
thing better better better better better
better I mean there's a ton of research
on this by the way Tim I mean you've
seen some of this research for example
on car purchases where you know you give
two groups you know this is the
treatment and control social science
experiments two groups different car
buying experiences for the first buys
their car and there's no refund and
there's no returns and the other side
can return it for any reason in the next
six months and the first group is much
happier with their car because they're
not thinking about it again and again
and again there's no more swiping you
know on on their car purchase and so the
same thing is when it's very easy to
have a lot of selection it gets much
much harder to to attain satisfaction
you're also exhausted more easily
because of the decision fatigue uh yeah
I mean I can I'll have to take your word
for it but I mean that's certainly true
that's in the data
not outside of dating yeah just in
general yeah right but the bigger
problem actually comes because we're
looking for the wrong thing and a
partner the data suggests that what
everybody wants in a in a partner that
they can curate carefully because of the
online presence because of the platforms
is they want compatibility and they look
for compatibility with sameness to them
so I like this kind of food you do too
great I vote like this you do too great
on this religion or on no religion I
grew up here I went to college where did
you go to college et cetera they're not
looking for someone who doesn't speak
their language who they're looking for a
sibling and you know and and as as my
adult kids would say that's not hot yeah
the truth is we're way too compatible
and we're sorting on compatibility with
these technological means and the
biggest problem with dating today is
we're less and less attracted to people
we're less and less attracted because
they're too much like us we need more
complementarity and less compatibility
this is a back in the old days you say
opposites attract not true but you need
a baseline of compatibility but on top
of that you need difference difference
is hot difference is fun differences in
adventure and you're just not gonna find
it because nobody's gonna swipe on you
quite frankly if you're the other party
and you know a lot of people curate on
you know language and culture and race
it's Insanity you know that's the reason
that good old-fashioned human people who
say they could fall in love when you
talk about people who fix you up on a
blind date or or the old-fashioned
matchmakers they're always looking about
about complementarity this introvert and
this extrovert can fill in the gaps in
each other in a kind of a Divine and
Cosmic way
and that's kind of how I always felt
that's how I always kind of felt I felt
like my wife was you know I don't
believe in magical thinking on this
magical thinking is a big problem
because soul mates don't exist and
there's no such thing as love at first
sight but I always do feel like my wife
Esther was
she was picked for me she was really
picked for me and because because of the
difference as much as anything else I
mean she completes me she makes me a
better man she knows when I'm going
after the idol she knows she can see it
going after the Lord she can see it
she's like right and that's 32 years of
experience together but it's also the
Deep complimentary that came through
because like I was born at a particular
time and I accidentally had this kind of
experience and that's what we need
that's number one this is clear the
second thing is goals goals you know
when I ask people you know
you're gonna meet
the person of your dreams or the good
enough person or whatever
what do you want to have after five
years the good enough
Person's Guide to the good enough life
two passable relationships
wife me up with someone good enough man
anyway so yeah I know
but because by the way step one the
criminal record their art just kidding I
don't know man complimentary yeah maybe
it's like you've been in prison I
haven't you know we complete each other
whatever I've been trying isn't working
maybe I'll skip Barcelona and do the
prison circuit all right but when you
ask people what do you want your
relationship to look like in five years
they have kind of this magical notion of
an ongoing passion and that's the wrong
goal the right goal is what was what is
called companionate love you want to be
best friends in five years five years to
best friends that's the goal yeah I like
that and if you write it out and if you
actually make it the goal and then you
have interim steps and a strategic plan
you might just get there but if you're
like yeah no no it's like if the magic
feels like the magic's gone obviously
there's something wrong with our love no
best friends who are married they're
gonna have plenty of passion but you
can't live like that look the
neurophysiological Cascade of the
experience of falling in love is
unbelievably intense it's Fourth of July
in your head you know that bolus of
testosterone and estrogen in in at the
very beginning of the relationship that
massive increases in norepinephrine and
and and dopamine that give you Euphoria
and and concentration and focus on the
other person the Deep dip in serotonin
your serotonin depths why because you
want to ruminate on that person you
using the good old ventral lateral
prefrontal cortex that's the reason that
falling in love is an awful lot like
being clinically depressed so you're
both addicted to meth and depressed at
the same time that's what falling in
love is like and then you're going to
get that big big big dose of oxytocin
which is the neuropeptide that that
links you to the other person in this
almost magical confusing way man that's
just too much you don't want that for
the rest of your life sounds like a lot
well you'll be institutionalized
all right so let's let's pause there for
a second that was a lot it was a lot I
want to go are you over stimulated I
want to go I want to go from falling in
love as meth and depression to the
lightness of death
and we haven't even talked about meaning
yet man oh we're going to get there
we'll get there by the night I'm keeping
I'm keeping track now we're nine yeah
I'm keeping track hour nine I have a
bookmarked meaning
also I have promised I made to listeners
that I have not fulfilled which is your
personal examples for using money for
experiences time whatever comes to mind
right so we'll get to that but before
that death meditation yeah could could
you please
describe your death meditation and why
you have a death meditation
most people watching us are not afraid
of death not pathologically afraid of
death only about 20 of the population is
pathologically afraid of death and I bet
you that it's less than one percent of
Tim Ferriss followers
because people watching this are in
control of their lives and they
understand the Contours of their lives
and they're you know they're they're
looking at the truth of their lives
but they have a death fear the deaf fear
isn't physical death
and this is a problem for some people
it's irrelevance for some people it's
being forgotten for a lot of your
listeners it's failure just straight on
failure because they're Strivers they're
achievers
everybody has a deaf fear and what is it
it's an ego thread it's a threat to who
you see as yourself if Tim ferriss's Tim
ferrissness is threatened that will
provoke a panic in you because that's
the ultimate death of who you see
yourself the way to get over that and by
the way you have to get over that we all
have to get over that or we won't be
fully Alive until we actually face the
death that really matters to us this is
an Insight that actually comes from the
theravada Buddhists across the Southern
Tier of
of Asia from Thailand and Myanmar to
Vietnam and parts of Malaysia and the
third one in Sri Lanka in particular so
the theravana Buddhist monasteries often
you'll go in and you'll see
photos of cadavers in different states
of decomposition
super super Macabre I mean you're like
what are these dudes all about here
and what they do is that usually there
will be nine nine states of
decomposition photos bodies decomposing
falling apart bones
bloated corpses and they stand in front
of each one and they say that is me
and then they move to the next one after
contemplating and saying and that is me
and what are they doing they're
familiarizing themselves with the truth
of their future such that they can be
liberated from any fear of physical
death
only then can they be fully alive that's
a that's an important Insight from from
theravada Buddhism that's a that's a
meditation called maranasati Mara in the
Sun the marinasati deaf meditation
now when I read that I thought it was
interesting but I thought
it's a good thing to do because you know
I shouldn't be making all of these
decisions about when I'm old and when
I'm retired and you know when I die and
what's going to happen and call the
lawyer and all that I want to be free
from all that stuff but by understanding
that life and death are in in a very
real way an illusion
particularly because I believe in
eternal life
but I have a death here
oh yeah
you know what I'm afraid of you know my
deaf fear
who's going to take care of your cats no
I don't know
that's good man who's gonna take care of
my dog Chicho
it's losing my mind on the way there
yeah because you know you know what
Arthur Brooks is gray matter look I'm
not the smartest guy in the world I'm
not the cleverest guy in the world but I
make my living and I support my family
and I understand me in terms of my ideas
literally my company is called ACB ideas
right
it was very revealing to me when I
contemplated the fact that I do say ACB
yeah it's my Arthur Charles okay it took
me a second
I can't remember the alphabet a little
dyslexic
all right he's like xzy Anyway from Long
Island sorry guys
yeah so
and my mother was showing signs of
dementia in her early 50s
and she was quite demented by the time
she was my age wow and it runs in
families yeah it's genetic I know it
doesn't mean I'm gonna get the bullet it
doesn't mean I'm not being I'm not being
morbid about it I'm not being fatalistic
about it probably the odds are in my
favor but I'm just I'm just terrified of
that
and when I recognize that I realized I
need a marinasati meditation on that and
that's what I contemplate
I'll take two minutes and I'll think
my memory is failing and I don't know
why
and then I imagine going to the
neurologist the neurologist saying well
I think you need to come into my office
and then I imagine myself telling my
kids
the future is going to be rough
and then I imagine
my work slipping away
my inability to have this kind of
conversation to write a book to share an
idea to help somebody with these ideas
and then I imagine myself not
remembering what I don't remember
then I imagine being a beloved Son of
God
with no memory at all
now it's heavy right seems like that
ending point is important
it's the most important because you end
on the truth
so if you're not religious you just end
up to use the parlance of the kids these
days just pressed AF I mean are you just
no out of luck no okay because at
the end of the day in the Marana Sati
meditation you recognize the illusion of
the tragedy that was your death in the
first place
ashes to ashes dust to dust new life
will emerge will it be you will it be
somebody else do you care
see when you look into the abyss you can
cope with it you're stronger than that
here my students by the way at Harvard
graduate students Harvard Business
School best in the world so we like to
think
they're afraid of failure because
they've never failed they've never
failed I mean you and I have struggled
and you know we're older and you know
I've failed a lot but my students are
deeply afraid of failure I mean I I
basically got kicked out of college when
I was 19. it turns out you're not
supposed to drop all your required
classes and take nothing but Indonesian
dance and North Indian classical
drumming turns out that's not the secret
to academic success kids you know make a
note of it
so I failed right but a lot of my
students haven't and so I asked them to
do the marinasati meditation on their
own academic and professional failure or
one
two minutes I I think I'm falling behind
academically and the people around me
are getting better grades
two
I just got put on academic probation
this was my dream to come to this school
and and I'm not succeeding
three
the job market is looking bad compared
to other people I can't believe it
four
I think I need to move home for a while
five
my parents feel sorry for me
that's when they cry
right because all you want is for Mom to
be proud of you
that's all you want when you're a
success addict that's all you want
and imagine that look into that stare
into it
stare into it and they do and they get
over it and they can Master it that's
the Marana Sati death meditation on the
self-objectification of the success
addict what do you see in those students
because they come from all different
backgrounds and different
orientations religious or not or
somewhere in between some are some
aren't yeah what types of effects and
how frequently do you personally do this
type of death meditation a lot because I
have my own death meditation I mean I
contemplate failure sometimes because
I'm afraid of it but I'm not deathly
afraid of it the truth of the matter is
the great thing about being 46 as
opposed to 26 for you the great thing
about being 59 is that at 29 for me
is that bad stuff is going to happen and
it's gonna be okay bad stuff's just
gonna happen right I mean the truth is
that we realize you and I both realize
that the worst thing that's ever
happened in life probably hasn't
happened yet
and okay that's heavy but it's not that
heavy you know we're gonna survive
you've survived a lot and that's
actually going to be okay I don't want
to fail you know I've always got you you
know we have that book coming out I have
a big book coming out you know a few
weeks from when we're taping this
episode
and I deeply wanted to be successful but
I can't control that and so I don't have
to do much more than a couple of Marina
Sati meditations on the on the you know
the market failure of a book but I have
to do it about losing my mind because
that feels deeply existential to me I
have to do it a lot I do it at least
once a week actually because I want to
remember I need to remember and if I
don't I'm going to be walking kind of on
eggshells and just sort of wondering and
and having that kind of minor sense of
dread I don't want to live that way I
don't need to live that way it's not
important for me to live that way on the
contrary it's important for me not to
live that way because I won't be fully
Alive now I'll be living prospectively
in the future and that future is
dominated by fear and then I'm really
not washing the dishes yeah I'm really
not enjoying that juicy Peach on the
contrary I'm breaking my teeth on the
pit
and it's not even a real Pit
[Music]
crazy
so not yet really yet yeah
this is I think is a good tie-in
to meaning and I'm going to get there
with a self-indulgent reference back to
Marcus Aurelius for people who've not
read meditations read meditations it was
never intended for publication it's
really these are effectively the pocket
musings of someone deeply conflicted but
also
incredibly impressive during war
campaigns and otherwise but lots of
thoughts on death and also for those
interested there's a it's considered a
stoic practice that exists in a lot of
different varieties but Memento Mori
there are these meditations
premeditative malorum right
exactly you also thought very deeply on
meaning let's come to meaning so we we
identified two I guess of the legs on
the stool on the stool right meaning
how should we think about me Minnie's a
hard one
meaning's the hard one I mean look I
mean enjoyment's no joke and
satisfaction takes work but meaning
eludes some people their entire lives
because they don't know what they're
looking for they're fumbling around for
something they don't know exactly what
it is and a lot of people they deeply
suspect that it doesn't exist
that it doesn't actually exist you look
at a lot of 20th century and 19th
century philosophers and they say it it
doesn't exist I mean there's sort of
three schools of thought about meaning
there's the ancient Greeks and Romans
and and the Christians and the Jews and
the Muslims and they all it's all kind
of based on meaning in the following way
Essence precedes existence meaning you
have meaning in life that precedes your
actual life and your job is to find it
and live up to it but it's already out
there you just need to go looking for it
right
in the 19th and 20th centuries that was
relaxed with two major schools of
philosophical thought nihilism and
existentialism existentialism you know
Sartre and even to a certain extent
Kierkegaard would say that existence
precedes essence in other words you're
born and there is no meaning until you
create it tabula rasa good luck kid yeah
good luck go make it and if it's no good
it's on you man and by the way sartro he
has a very empowering a very muscular
philosophy because he says you have to
live up to the responsibility of
creating your essence and living
according to it it's sort of Freudian in
this way and then of course there's
Niche our old pal Friedrich you know a
lot of young men love nietze because by
the way it's unbelievably beautiful
prose a gorgeous writer including in
English you don't have to go like learn
German to read it but you know the gay
science which is one of his most famous
texts where he said God is dead and we
kill them you know it's just it lands
right but his whole point Point his
existence is real but Essence is a
figment of your imagination so don't
even try to find it that's nihilism
right we're struggling with these
schools of thought and and we all
suspect it doesn't matter how religious
you are you know it doesn't matter what
your up your wiring actually happens to
be you kind of wonder if maybe May
chance Archer were right so you go in
search of it and it turns out I want to
go find the meaning of life is too big a
question you'll never find it by you
know sitting at the mouth of the guru's
cave
or or with the Ayahuasca Shaman saying I
just want to find meaning in life you
need to boil it down to really sub
questions which are all about coherence
why do things happen the way they do
I want to have it I need to believe
something about why things happen the
way they do it's going to be religious
it can be completely secular it might
even be nihilistic
you need a purpose you need to answer a
purpose question which is what's the
purpose of my life and what direction am
I going what's the goal of my life
what's the end point of my life
and alas's significance which is why
does it matter that I'm alive now I have
a test to see if somebody has a meaning
crisis in their life that's really just
two questions and to pass the test you
need
incredibly true honest and compelling
answers there's no right answers there's
only wrong answers or no answers so you
want to take the test
sure why not let's go time
question number one this is something
for all the Ayahuasca I've done go for
it I didn't say this there's something
wrong with it
what do we say it's necessary but not
something
myself
I left it back at the hotel yeah damn
why are you alive
do you have an answer to the question of
why you're alive
I mean I have a very clinical answer for
it tell me well I mean there's the
physical answer but but metaphysically
why are you alive
which can be two one of two things
either who created you or what you're
put on Earth to do you can answer that
in one of two ways do you have a strong
belief and why you're alive
I have a strong driver for taking
advantage of the fact that I am alive
but I don't have a
story of a Creator or something along
those lines I don't or of strong purpose
you know could it can be a Creator or a
purpose I do feel like I have a strong
purpose but it doesn't relate to my
birth
that's okay the why of your life or our
mutual friend Simon sinek talks about
this you know start with why and the why
of your life can be you know because of
a creation or it can be because I exist
to you know lift other people up and
bring them together in bonds of
happiness and love which by the way is
the why of my life so that's number one
and and if it's not if it's there but
it's in Kuwait
it's not quite clear enough
[Music]
find out the answer to that and write it
down and then perfect it over a
six-month period yeah I would say that
for me I mean it's it's looking at an
experiencing thing and things in
unorthodox ways so that I can teach and
why do you want to teach mostly to
alleviate suffering I would say in other
words you want to lighten the load for
other people yeah and so in other words
you want to serve your sisters and
brothers is that fair sure okay that's a
great why that's a great one that's a
great answer to the first question why
are you alive yeah I don't feel
conflicted about that okay so the second
one's harder for what would you be
willing to die today
I don't have a ready answer it's a hard
one it's a hard one a lot of people
don't for my faith for my family for my
country and for you
I am willing to die for others that's
the answer I mean I probably won't be
called to it but I'm willing to do it
I'm willing to do it I've come to the
conclusion that I'm actually willing to
do it and here's how I I learned this
from my son
I learned this actually from my son I
mean I have theoretical answers that are
politically correct in the Catholic
sphere I would die for the Catholic
church I would die for my faith these
things are true by the way I really
would
but it's too Pat here's how I learned
this for my son my son was
I have three kids 25 23 and 20. and my
middle son his name is Carlos and Carlos
is
um
he's a kinetic boy
he's a fan of yours you know he's
probably watching us right now going oh
my god oh dad's gonna talk about me
right now so Carlos sorry Carlos
and you know Carlos was having a good
old time in high school you know like
substantial grade problems and academic
issues and you know my wife's like at
least we know he's not cheating yeah
but the problem was he wasn't really
having fun you know and it was I think
it was a meaning problem and
in search of the answers to the
questions After High School
he really became an entrepreneur with
his life and you know we have I asked my
kids to do a business plan when they're
in high school because they're
entrepreneurs and I'm VC I'm an investor
I deserve a business plan and when
they're not when they weren't original
I'd send them back for revisions Bank of
Dad
yeah and it's really fun to be my son
you can imagine so
Carlos's business plan for his life by
the time it went through several rounds
of revisions was appropriately an
orthodox he was going to go work on a
Farm by himself and find the answers to
the questions
work hard and so he actually got a job
on a wheat farm in Idaho a real job not
some sort of you know hobby Farm no no
it was a 8 000 acre working wheat farm
he lived in the farmer's basement for
the first year he picked rocks out of
the soil he started at the bottom made
minimum wage fixed fences cut down dead
trees ran a combine by himself 16 hours
a day why did he choose this how would
he explain it because he needed to see
what he could do he needed to find out
what it meant to be Carlos Brooks away
from his family away from everybody why
because he was looking for the answers
to the questions they were in Kuwait
they were like what do I apply in my
life I don't know maybe I'll find it in
the Capitol combine maybe I'll find it
when I dig rocks out of the soil maybe
I'll find it by doing something hard
with my hands
then he joined the military
he was 19 years old to joined the Marine
Corps and boot camp is no walk in the
park for the US Marine Corps as we've
all heard but then it got harder from
there he did infantry training Battalion
and then the in dock for the scout
sniper platoon which is a branch of the
special forces in the
and the Marines today's Corporal Carlos
Brooks Marines 3-5 scout sniper platoon
and he's got answers
now that's a scary job for me and his
mom he goes on field trips right field
trips and thank God nothing's happened
to him he's getting out of the military
in in December of this year
but he's got answers what types of
answers I mean I don't want you to
here's his answers yeah I'll tell you
his answers
Carlos why are you alive
because God Made Me
for what are you willing to die
for my faith and for my family and for
my friends and for the United States of
America
boom these are not the answers that a
lot of people watching us would give but
these are super solid answers I'm super
proud of my son
because he earned the answers to his
meaning questions that everybody
watching us has got to earn it
everybody's watching us everybody who's
watching us has got to go on a quest A
Vision Quest for the answers to the
meaning questions there's no other way
to do it your dad can't tell you your
priest can't tell you
the holy books can give you inklings
they can give you Shadows on the cave
wall to get back to the old platonic
metaphor you need to live and to try
things to go through a process of
discernment
and the way to do that is to do hard
things is to challenge yourself and to
say to yourself I will not stop until I
have answers to these questions to my
own satisfaction
so hearing you describe Carlos's
experience
hi Carlos
and congratulations on the trajectory
this is like yeah my dad embarrassed me
but Tim Ferriss just said hi to me on
this podcast so it's all good and it's
not easy
I have some friends who are formerly
Marine forced recon yeah that is not the
Recon guys are not an easy pass no it
isn't none of that is easy yeah I think
I was over processing the for what would
you be willing to die tomorrow I think
it was the tomorrow piece right that I
fixated on so family right plus you
wouldn't ask your family you just would
yeah family and close friends I can give
that answer yeah right right I was
thinking of it more hypothetically as a
for what happening in the world would
you be willing to basically off yourself
is there an idea for what you'd be
willing to die is there a truth because
this is really where it gets super
intense yeah that's where it gets into
yeah when Carlos says I am willing to
die for my faith I am willing to die for
the United States of America which for
him is an ideal of Liberty he's by the
way for for those of you outside the
United States he's willing to die for
our allies too you know
dying for an idea that's super heavy I
mean that's like
pure grade meaning
because people are going to say are you
kidding me are you nuts
this is not I'm willing to kill for an
idea that's that's like you know that's
kindergarten stuff that's kindergarten
stuff now I'm willing to die for
something I'm willing to give my own
life I'm I'm willing to take yours yeah
you and every other you know half baked
dark Triad malignant narcissist cancel
culture trait psychopath I thought you
were talking to me for a second
Arthur Brooks got really abusive on my
pocket no no no no no Tim I love you
that you're a beautiful man but but I
mean I mean come on I mean it's
everybody around the world is willing to
you know kill for you know what they
think or cancel or hurt people what they
think but the real question is are you
willing to sacrifice what you have for
an idea and that's
that's really hard yeah I'm not sure
that's a tough one for me to answer I
think also thinking about what you're
willing to die for let me personalize it
thinking about what I'm willing to die
for I also want to be very aware
if there are things I would be willing
to die for that
could be manipulated to make me do
things that I might not
currently be morally aligned with
totally totally so for sure I get the
allegiance I get it it needs to be a
very or for me I want to be aware of
their things like for instance faith has
been manipulated by politicians so has
patriotism of course my goodness right I
mean a lot of people listening say you
die for the United States of America
you're crazy which is not to say that
it's wrong it's just very context
dependent very context dependent and it
requires
a lot of updating and serious thought
and it's not good enough to just be sort
of
raw raw raw and taking it to face value
it takes serious discernment so we have
the
why were you born or for what why are
you alive are you alive
what would you be willing to die for
yeah
got any more those are the ones I mean
what those do is that they really kind
of wrap up coherence purpose and
significance into two kind of Handy
Dandy questions and and the point is
really this I mean it's it's easy for me
to to frame that up is you know once you
find those you're all good to go all
right but the truth is you're going to
go through the rest of your life
contemplating these things and these are
the questions to ask on your birthday do
these are these still the things that I
believe have I updated my knowledge do I
have a better sense of who I am have I
have I gone backwards a little bit if I
lost this sense of what I'm willing to
die for do I need to go a little deeper
at this point and and touching up on
those questions turns out to be a really
good it's sort of the same thing when
you go to the doctor and they do the
same test again and again and again and
again I have a series of tests that I do
or these questions that I ask myself
like that you know about the reverse
bucket list and the meaning questions
and am I pursuing my Pleasures socially
and and making memory with my prefrontal
cortex I also have by the way a
spreadsheet of of 19 micronutrients that
feed into my macronutrients and I myself
on tenths of one percent on a one to ten
scale weighted with respect to what I've
what my my best estimate of my
well-being and when I'm going backwards
on those things I said a strategic plan
for my year so I'm you know
I know I'm getting Crazier by the minute
right I'm into it I encourage it I want
to pour gasoline on the fire let's do it
man so I I so we already talked about
death meditation we talked about your
experience in Mexico and in build a life
you want obviously we're not going to go
into all the micronutrients of each of
the legs on the stool per se but I'm
curious whether it's meaning or one of
the others maybe meaning
but doesn't have to be could you give
some examples of some of those
I don't say antecedents but
micronutrients right the cast of
characters and ingredients
that are important for sort of healthy
functioning for sure for sure and you
can break them up and it's variated ways
you want you could make 20 000 of them
but really there's four that we should
be thinking about so there's four
fundamental micronutrients and I make it
more varied than that I've got 19
because because they're really about
love and relationships that's really
what it's all about and the big four are
your search for the Divine or your
spiritual journey or your philosophical
you know your faith whatever that
happens to be religious or not
your love for something bigger than you
so you can stand it off it's your family
relationships this is the most mystical
kinds of love that we get because we
didn't choose the loves that were chosen
for us and sometimes we're like yeah I
wouldn't have chosen that
friendship you know and friendship when
I'm talking about that I talk a lot
about loneliness because especially
Strivers hard-working people a lot of
people watching us there they have a lot
of people around them but what they have
is deal friends but not real friends
your deal friends are super useful to
you your real friends are useless
cosmically beautifully useless and so I
go into a lot of detail with my students
about how to build useless friendships
not worthless that's different I've got
those two and last but not least it's
loving everybody's expressed through
your work and that means serving others
with your work your work should be a
service profession no matter what you're
doing and so faith family friends and
work and then there's you know we Branch
out from there you know what I'm talking
about family I'm talking about different
branches of family that I'm trying to
make sure I'm working on I'm talking
about you know my marriage is critically
important it gets one of the absolute
highest scores in importance not always
in terms of quality because I'm not the
best husband but but in terms of
importance for sure and that's because
that's the Apex of two of those columns
both family and friendship my best
friend and also the adopted member of my
family is my wife and so therefore my
marriage is really at the top of those
two pillars and so I'm thinking about
that a lot so I break it up into
subcategories but they all go into those
silos of faith family friends and work
work that serves work is Meaningful
right earn my success and then I say
okay well you know what does it mean to
earn my success what does it mean to
serve others how do I know et cetera et
cetera et cetera when I start you know
getting down to Brass tax I start
putting numbers on it and if the numbers
aren't
if I'm going backwards in a particular
year I do it my birthday and my off
birthday by the way you're off birthday
yeah yeah my six month birthday November
21st got it my birthday's May 21st so
whatever 21st you got Thanksgiving week
yeah I've got Thanksgiving week and so
it gives me you know a chance to
actually think about these things in in
some detail to be sure and then I've got
it you know I've got the data going back
to about the year 1999. I've got it
going forward and this system has gotten
better along the way and changed what
are the most important changes you've
made to the system would you say yeah
the most important change the single
most important change I made of the
system
was a recognition that I knew a lot
about happiness but wasn't happy because
I was studying it but I wasn't doing it
the biggest change to the system was
using my knowledge to change my habits
that was number one Far and Away right
it's one thing I was giving people all
this all this advice about friendships
and about any good marriage and all that
like
I was looking at my life and I wasn't
living these things I was just like
everybody else you know waking up going
sure hope I feel happy today it was
pathetic it was pathetic it was like you
know like a drug and alcohol counselor
getting up and you know taking a bunch
of bong hits and having a six-pack yeah
that's what it was it was craziness and
by the way it was my wife who finally
clued me she's like you have a PhD right
what are you using it for exactly I mean
you're like your English has come a long
way you're killing me sweetheart you
killed me but you know I'm running
academic Journal articles that 14 people
read so I can get promotion in tenure it
was ridiculous
so how did you I imagine even if you're
not necessarily walking the walk as much
as you would like you believe in what
you are sharing so it wasn't necessarily
a conviction issue right so how do you
then translate it to action are you just
like you know what if it's not in the
calendar it's not real let me commit to
things that I block out so that they are
unavoidable in a sense yeah how did you
convert it well I started by doing
habits and practices that were very very
specific I mean extremely specific as
specific as the stuff in the you know
the four-hour body specific and I was
writing stuff down I held whole
notebooks of protocols and things that I
was trying I was trying things on myself
based on science and when it worked I
would keep it and I would write it down
and practice it turns out that wasn't
good enough
because it's very easy to have you know
because that was too hacky you know that
wasn't really habits to ingrain a habit
you got to do one more step which is
that you got to teach it the reason I'm
a happiness Professor is because I want
to lash myself to the Mast and I want to
be completely committed because look I
mean if I'm doing something that's
clearly at odds with what I'm teaching
I'm going to hear about it I'm going to
hear about it from my students I'm going
to hear about it from my family I'm
going to hear about it
good Lord I'm going to hear about it on
on social media not that I'm paying that
much attention to that because I want to
be happy and it's really really
important so basically there's a
protocol in my life which is number one
understand number two practice number
three share and that's the protocol that
works for everybody when it comes to
happiness you got to take those three
steps you got to do the work and
understand it it's funny because I've
done all this work over the years with
the Dalai Lama and he always says the
same thing
if you want to be a spiritual adept
think more feel less
think more feel less I would not expect
no exactly the framing okay what is that
means well he first wakes up in the
morning and the first two hours of his
meditation he gets up at 3 or 3 30 in
the morning the first thing that he does
after a little bit on his exercise bike
and hanging out with his cat the first
thing that he does is two hours of
analytical meditation which Catholics
call mental prayer that means you take a
couple of lines of sacred scripture and
you you analyze it and you think about
it most learning doesn't happen when the
when the professor talks about something
if you understand everything the
professor says it's not a hard enough
class and you don't have a very good
professor he has to blow your mind with
something and you got to go away and
think about it and then you learn it
through your own thinking that's
analytical meditation or mental prayer
and is the Dalai Lama using scripture in
this sense yeah Tibetan Buddhist
scripture so he's contemplating
something for you know words of the
Buddha or Shanti Deva or any of the
ancient tactical questions is he
choosing it or is it flip open the book
and which would not denigrate it I'm
just wondering drop the needle yeah I
mean no it's extraordinary I mean the
the holy scriptures for Tibetan
Buddhists are vast there's a library in
dharamsala that's just stack after stack
after stack after stack it's not a Bible
it's not like a collection of books in
the little Library called The Bible and
it's just it's enormous and and the the
monks are going through the scriptures
again and again and again so he has I'm
sure he hasn't explained it to me but
I'm sure that he has actually a regular
rotation that he's going through to do
his and that's what we need to do he's
got the equivalent of these 10 exercises
when you go to the gym skip the bench
press like he's got yeah kinda his
Greatest Hits no doubt yeah that's
really important to do in the science of
happiness is to is to look at what you
know the best protocols you know what
does it mean to
stand up to your negativity bias by
actually practicing gratitude when what
you're feeling is resentment how do you
do that how do you actually achieve a
state of metacognition awareness of your
own feelings such that you can choose
reactions in the face of emotions how
can you get into the state of the eye
self which is the state in which you're
observing the world as opposed to
observing yourself well it starts with
knowledge of what these concepts are and
then you put it into practice as real
exercises I have a column in the
Atlantic that comes out every Thursday
morning that's next on my list of
questions the third part of every column
is do these three things is taking the
science and then applying to your life
in these three ways it's application and
change of habits and a commitment to
that and the best way to cement in those
ideas by lashing yourself to the Mast
and that's by teaching these things to
everybody else and everybody look I have
I have a lab at Harvard called the
leadership and happiness lab the whole
point of the lab is not bench science
and pouring stuff into test tubes or
doing new experiments it's learning how
we can all be happiness teachers how can
Tim Ferriss be a happiness teacher we
already are working on that and we're
working on it and there's no reason that
you have to be happy to be a happiness
teacher this is not like playing
basketball thank God yeah totally I mean
on the contrary the people have
struggles the best I'm not as miserable
as some you're pretending to be I mean
the point is that you're right but but I
do have struggles I mean
you're self-aware you're self-aware and
part of your commitment because I know
your work part of your commitment to
lifting other people up is sharing your
journey this is what it comes down to so
you joke about you know but but the
truth of the matter is we're all uh we
all are and sharing that is actually
part of the way that you're practicing
these protocols you're not hacking
anything you're actually trying to build
these habits and then the teaching role
you're you're a teacher by the way
because this is a teaching podcast we're
not shooting the breeze and saying
what'd you see on TV and uh I went to a
new restaurant no we're talking about
heavy stuff because we actually want to
teach these ideas and lift other people
up so that's that's the secret man learn
learn more think more I don't feel learn
things second turn this into habits and
practice those habits third share with
others and commit to other people
through your teaching that's the secret
of happiness
commit commit in what sense just sort of
energetically taking the magnifying
glass off of yourself and committing to
actually these practices in your own
life right you know and this can often
be
I've been doing this thing wrong and I
don't want to keep doing this thing
wrong and me telling you is making
yourself accountable to another person
like all 12-step programs work this way
right
honestly 12-step programs AAA some of
the most important and impressive
decentralized organizations I've ever
seen yeah and I've never participated
but I I'm so impressed but they require
accountability yeah because basically
what 12-step programs do is knowledge of
what's wrong with me committing to new
habits and sharing it with others that's
why AAA works is because of those three
steps as well they do sneak some God in
there well yeah the higher power for
sure the higher power which is helpful
yeah yeah I'm not going to deny it one
facet that I really appreciate of your
work in your writing is that you you
straddle the very old and the very new
yeah and you mentioned Aquinas earlier
again everybody read a few pages at
least on Wikipedia about Aquinas and
then Aristotle and one of you were
popular columns is about Aristotle's 10
secrets to happiness I wonder if any I
do have them in front of me you know
because I can't remember them yeah I was
just gonna say the problem would make my
weekly copy you know let me how about
this how about I read through yeah and
then I would love for you to pick out
one or two perhaps that have been
particularly impactful for you or for
your readers right here we go name your
fears and face them
two know your appetites and control them
three be neither a cheapskate nor a
spendthrift four give as generously as
you can five focus more on the
Transcendent disregard the trivial six
true strength is a controlled temper
seven Never Lie especially to yourself
eight stop struggling for your fair
share nine forgive others and forbear
their weaknesses ten Define your
morality live up to it even in private
and I want to take one off the table
sure which is the last one because
there's a there's a recency bias here
since we've been talking I think fairly
extensively about that but yeah those
are there we go so
start with number seven all right Never
Lie be impeccable with your word
especially with you now I know a lot of
people
who are pretty honest
frankly the reason my wife fell in love
with me is not my you know my stunning
good looks and you know my my lousy
accent and the gray hair at the time
it's right here no great hair great hair
I know I mean it was spectacular if I do
say so and so but yeah the reason she
told me later is because I was the first
man that never lied to her I never lied
now that's part of my upbringing and you
know that's has to do with your family
Etc that was a really super important
value in my home
there were
you had to be honest the only really you
know dramatic and and and and scary
consequences with my parents were from
lying
don't lie don't lie don't lie and so the
result is it was kind of in a way easier
for me because the way that I was raised
but I was the first guy she'd ever met
that didn't lie she's like what's up
with this dude he doesn't lie and and
I've procured you know when my when my
oldest son both of my sons 25 and 23
they're both married and when my 25 year
old 25 and 23 both married they're both
married yeah wow I need to get
relationship advice from your sons well
my older son he's a piece of work I mean
he's
I learned a lot from him he's literally
one of the brightest native intelligence
people I've ever met but he also has
this this super
adroit moral instinct to him and he
asked me he said
tell me one thing
that I should never do because I'm in
love with this girl that I should never
do he asks you know good questions like
that I thought about I said it's
actually pretty easy never lied to her
ever ever ever ever ever until you go to
the Grave never lie to her and ask her
never to lie to you no matter what the
consequences
now that's that's the secret to to the
pure oxygen of a true companionate love
the mystical love of
the romance where you feel truly chosen
for each other it has to be based on
honesty it has to be and a lot of people
are like yeah yeah good luck with that I
mean
right but
and there are lots of things it doesn't
mean you have to say by the way
sweetheart your butt looks fat in that I
was just gonna ask you yeah no no no
volunteer every single thing that you're
thinking because you're not insane
but when there's a direct question
there's a direct answer that's what it
comes down to okay that's fine but
that's
you say in Spanish
that's you know that's terrible steaks
table Stakes man you want to really be
in the game never lie to yourself
and we're doing it all the time we're
doing it all the time we don't want to
face up to the truth we don't want to
look really in the mirror and not not so
that we can you know think how great our
hair looks or whatever but so we can
actually see the good and the bad
and to say I'm a true human being that's
a hard thing to do when people lie to
themselves constantly and Aristotle
talked about that and Aquinas and and
the Buddha and you know one of the
things that they all have in common is
that they have this impeccable idea of
self-honesty which is that's taking a
draft of the purest liquor of life like
yeah I can drink that I'm gonna drink
that really you're tough enough to drink
that and once you start doing that I
mean it's just it's it's it's it's hard
it's really hard but it's life-changing
yeah so I have a question about that and
it also makes me think about some of the
scientists I respect most like Richard
Feynman who he says You must not fool
yourself and you're the easiest person
to fool for sure and a lot of people say
because I'm religion I'm religious that
I'm fooling myself right so this well
this leads not to a religion specific
question but rather just to a fine
slicing which is right sometimes and I'm
going off the cuff so this isn't going
to be polished but we lie to ourselves
in the sense that we have a story about
ourselves or the world right that we
know isn't quite true but we repeated
enough because we want it to be true
then there are times when we lie to
ourselves but we are
we are in the delusion right like it is
because we have a lack of awareness or
who knows right there there are
any number of factors that have fed into
this belief which is simply not accurate
for whatever
for whatever reason so how do you catch
how do you catch yourself like are there
could you give examples hypothetical or
otherwise of
because I think most people say I don't
want to lie to myself right but when it
comes down to actually catching those
catching those self-lies that
self-deception in the in the butterfly
net so you can do something with that
right how do you how do you do that well
you commit yourself to being
uncomfortable for one thing so there's a
couple of different ways to do that
number one is you you seek outside
counsel you ask people who really know
you well you ask them to be committed to
telling you the absolute truth and then
you ask them incredibly hard questions
about yourself right and
you should have friends that can do that
for you this is one of the ways that you
can do it your friends really have to be
able to tell you both being a good
friend usually means telling you
convenient lies that's not the right
Criterion for your closest friends your
real friends your real friends who
should be like buddy
I don't think you're being
straightforward with that right now so
this is I'm making I'm doing a fake
Atlanta accent because my my best friend
is a guy named Frank and he lives in
Atlanta and he and we are committed to
telling each other the truth and boy
does he ever give it to me both barrels
when he thinks I'm being full of it
buddy
I don't know I don't know I know you're
saying that thing but let's drill down
on that a little bit shall we
talked to him every week that's super
important every week sure I talked to
because he's a real friend and that
takes work right no I understand but is
that like you have a a not standing no
but he's somebody where we're committed
to When the Call Comes in it says Frank
I take the call even if it's during work
time I take the call but otherwise you
know you can't take every single call
that comes in you know I
there are certain colleagues certain
family members and Frank and have you
guys explicitly
made some type of mutual commitment and
the reason I ask is there are
environments also that I suppose I could
join but I I haven't up to this point
for instance YPO forums these small
groups those are quite good they are
very good six seven eight guys
benefited from it tremendously and
they're as I understand it based on my
friend's stories there are many hot seat
moments where you get your beliefs and
stories and approaches and strategies
interrogated and you are committed in a
YPO forum
to have your BS called out yeah so if
you're saying something you know it's
not true about you there's some great
rules people can study it also if you
wanted to try to mimic or replicate it I
guess for a lot of folks and I I hate to
say it but I think especially men they
may not have
sort of a codified setting like that men
especially successful men tend to get
lonelier and lonely as they get older
yeah women tend to get less and less
lonely but men tend to get lonely or
lonelier so about 60 of 60 year old men
say their best friend is their wife
about 30 of their wives say their best
friend is their husband oh this is the
story of a sad story of unrequited
friendship
unrequited companion to love at home for
sure but you know what that means is
that a lot of women have very very close
friends that they've cultivated usually
through family life and community life
and guys you know it's like hey man I
worked so hard over the years and you
know hanging out with my friends is
stealing from my family I'm not gonna go
golfing for five hours on Saturday you
know when the kids are little it'll be
terrible at home I'll get yelled at and
yada yada yada all kinds of excuses and
pretty soon they're lonely I mean the
loneliness is a big big topic sure and
the bonding and and this these types of
communal relationships but as far as
cultivating a relationship with the
friends that you have that unvarnished
feedback and interrogation might you
have any suggestion for how to approach
that well there's two ways to do it
there's the there's the organic way and
there's the manual way the organic way
is that you don't lose those true
friends that you've had usually since
you were a young adult yep and and a lot
of people do I mean we move around a lot
we're really ambitious and our friends
wind up being our deal friends yeah you
know and and our real friends you know
people will say I mean I'll do an
exercise where I'll say tell me the 10
people that are closest to you write
them down real quick I can do it easily
yeah yeah I literally have it in a
spreadsheet that's great and then put
real ordeal after each one of those
names based on the fact that and for you
it's all real right because you have
close friends right yeah I do a high
percentage from a long time ago and you
and you travel with them and you do
stuff with them right I put a lot of
energy and time into ensuring that we
spend time together which gets harder as
people have wives and kids and children
and yeah for sure Family Life tends to
get in the way of that but you have to
do it's like anything else you got to do
the work I'm I'm unfettered by for
direct family life since but you know
and the data say that in 10 years you'll
most likely be married yeah and have
kids and it's going to be harder but you
you'll have to put it
folks let's work on this shall we
write in the comments your best yeah all
right so this is the organic way yeah
the organic way which is you know is
make sure that you don't lose track of
your real friends and you have a
commitment with your real friends to
hold you to a standard of honesty in the
friendship and with yourself because
that's what true friendship really
entails the manual way is the YPO Forum
way where there's a bunch of guys that
you know that are usually deal friends
and you make a deal to make them into
real friends you make a deal it's like
you know it's an arrangement where part
of the Friendship is actually going to
be to go deeper
to hold each other's secrets to be
honest with each other and that can
actually be incredibly effective because
you've actually decided to do that and
people will live up to those particular
promises psychological safety is really
important in that too right because it's
one thing to say I want you to be
completely honest with me and say yeah
you're a jerk it's like not that honest
or you know don't express it in that
particular way you have to have enough
psychological safety sort of and where
the rules of the road are clear that
honesty is always wield this is a gift
and never as a weapon that's also true
in marriages by the way Tim the best
marriages are completely honest but the
honesty is a gift and never a weapon
yep you know one of the mantras at
Facebook before it was meta was Facebook
is a gift maybe feedback is a gift
feedback is a gift feedback is a gift it
was repeated over and over again just
put all over the place yeah to cultivate
a culture of feedback yeah and I've
thought about that
just grabbing these little Snippets make
yourself small I mean these these very
pithy reminders that will have some
stickiness in the mind
and and also doubling down on having
your friends act as the best mirrors
available very brief side note just to
give people a Scooby Snack
mirrors Reflections what are your
thoughts get rid of them
all of them tell me more so I work with
the guy
he's fantastic he actually is he's
really really helpful for me I've
recommended him to to you because he
does incredible Bodywork
physical therapy is fantastic and you
know he was a fitness model yeah there's
almost nothing you can do that's
unhealthier worse for your mental health
than being a fitness model or Fitness
influencer why because you're just
looking in the mirror all day long and
your your physical appearance is that on
which you will be judged is very
emotionally warping and he hated it he
hated it he hated he was unhappy he
never ate what he wanted for 10 years
you know and and the truth of the matter
is as we all know
you look great if your body fat is under
10 but you feel crummy and you want
everybody in the world to die
[Laughter]
it can be really really hard on you and
he said but after a while you know
there's a reason that 35 of people who
lose a lot of weight when they get to
their goal they keep going and a quarter
of them develop an eating disorder the
reason is because you you can't stop
when you're looking in the mirror all
the time you can't stop you can't stop
you don't know how to stop
so he had the presence of mind he's an
Adept he's a spiritual adept
he got rid of all of his mirrors and
showered in the dark for a year
he got rid of all of the mirrors in his
house the showering in the dark I need
well because she kept your abs
watching the water Cascade off your 12th
back like rocks in a waterfall I know
and the truth of the matter is that that
I hate when that happens
extreme but yes I get a physical
attractiveness ordinarily is something
that you do because you want to become
more lovable and you make that judgment
on the basis of what you're seeing in
the mirror and not the relationship that
you're projecting to others in real life
it's really weird you know you talk to
dudes who are trying to get to you know
six percent body fat and get super
jacked in the whole thing and they
imagine that women are going to be just
super attracted to them and the only
people who even say anything are dudes
oh it's always dudes it's like it's like
I have friends with
single guys and they have incredible
beard game yeah or like mustache game
and non-stop it's just dudes coming up
and complimenting them
I mean I'm sure there are women who like
it too but it's mostly guys yeah for
sure
you know no woman has ever said nice car
I mean it's just no it's other guys is
the whole thing and what that is is the
other guys are just a mirror they're
just a mirror the other guys are saying
the thing that you think it's profoundly
unsatisfying right if you're actually in
the heterosexual dating Market you have
other guys saying how did you get those
abs who cares now to provide a counter
example also and this is just something
I've seen
on dating apps that she could talk about
but
I have yet to meet a single guy I like
and respect who's like I love super
intense lip fillers and all of this you
know Franken Botox situation I've not
met a single one I know and have you
ever said I've never said to my wife one
time that's such a cute little dress is
it new
I've never said that all her friends say
that and she's always like
I have a cute little dress and everybody
noticed it but you didn't
for the record I'm into cute little
dresses
just just I don't I don't want people to
mix up voices here the show notes just
went
so why did you write this book and how
did it come to be I know you have this
long history with thinking about these
catalyzing events and tracking
and I don't say pursuing but analyzing
thinking deeply about happiness so why
why now and what do you hope that it
will accomplish
so this new book is the most bread and
butter book I've ever written about the
science of Happiness it's two parts part
one is how to manage your emotions so
they don't manage you part two is once
you've got that down now you can
actually build your life and not be
distracted and figuring away your time
with stupid things those are the two
parts of the book and it says Deep dive
as I've ever actually written publicly
about Neuroscience it was actually
vetted by my my colleague at Harvard
Josh crane is one of the most
distinguished neuroscientists in the
world just to make sure because I'm a
social scientist so I got to be careful
you know getting into the biology side
of this thing you know I know enough to
be dangerous to be sure but I have to be
very careful about that so I realized
and by the way this project was
instigated to do a bread and butter
owner's manual on you and your happiness
that's what it is it's an owner's manual
on your happiness
it wasn't my idea it was Oprah Winfrey's
idea so you you occupy some rarefied air
so from the Dalai Lama how does does you
just bump into around the subway yeah
his Holiness her Holiness Oprah Winfrey
yes exactly yeah I mean it's you know an
Oprah Winfrey calls it's like oh right
but yeah I'm guessing she didn't get
your phone number on Zoom info like how
how did this happen yeah she calls I'm
like yeah and I'm Batman no really who
is this no hi it's Oprah calling again
your company has been verified by dun
and Bradstreet oh wait a minute anyway
so we got connected because she is a
regular reader of my calling the
Atlantic and she was during the
coronavirus epidemic when you know
people were trying to use the time to
learn new things Etc and she was
actually a serious read of the column
and she's a serious reader she's a
serious reading when she has a book on
her podcast she reads the book it's just
amazing how exhaustive her knowledge is
and then when my book came out from
strength to strength and in February
2022 she got it literally in the first
week she read it and that's when she
called and she said would you come on my
podcast her Super Soul which is this
book podcast phenomenal and we were like
a house on fire from the very beginning
because
she's it's funny because you know you've
met a lot of famous people and you know
I've met some famous people and they're
usually not exactly like they appear in
public right
she's like she appears in public I mean
she's calm she's smart she's nice she's
funny
she's awesome she's actually what people
think she is she's an authentic she's
truly an authentic person and so we
really got along and we have the
synchronicity of mission which is to
lift people up and bring them together
in bonds of happiness and love but we
have different platforms for doing it
I'm teaching this class on the science
of happiness at Harvard University and
writing in the Atlantic
she has been in in mass media forever
and whenever she weighs in she has
millions and millions and millions of
people around the world that trust her
and want to hear what she has to say and
so her suggestion was let's take that
class that you teach at Harvard and that
you're writing about in the Atlantic
let's present that to a big audience you
want a big audience I said yeah yes yes
I yes Oprah can I have a big audience
please
and she says let's write a book together
and we'll present this book together and
so we did and you know we got together
at her home and we framed it up we
framed up the book over a three or four
day period last year
in her tea house in Montecito California
it's like you know I was looking around
going you know I'm just like the small
town
college professor who fell off the
turnip truck in front of Oprah's Tea
House you never know he's like God Bless
America you never know what's going to
happen and and it was super fun it was
super interesting for people who want to
work hard oh my goodness oh my goodness
and she's a the best case study in
American success and and and working
hard and believing in others and paying
it forward possible so we went and we
started working on our respective parts
of the book and passing them back and
forth and I took a house in San Clemente
in California for six weeks in the
winter largely to look at the Pacific
Ocean to write the book and she was
writing her parts and we got to this
impasse at one point not between us but
because the title didn't fit
the title now is how to build the life
you want the Art and Science of getting
happier and it was called Fully Alive
and it wasn't fitting and I didn't know
and finally Oprah calls me and she says
got the wrong title she's a genius we
got the wrong title this is a how-to
book this is an owner's manual book this
is really a how-to book on your own
happiness this should be called how to
build the life you want and kaching the
whole thing fell into place because
that's what happens as you know in the
course of writing a book you think you
have it but you don't and then when the
title actually completes the book and
allows you to finish the book and and
make it all here then we finished it up
and it was this amazing collaborative
experience a joy actually it was the
most fun it was the most positive
experience I've ever had writing a book
because
I got to write it with her and she's
enriched my life
what a wild incredible experience it's
nuts
that's nuts man you know that I told you
my deaf fear is is losing my mind it's
actually possible that I am and that's
just a hallucination
[Laughter]
tea and then we have trumpets
him I know I want the pure truth but if
that's not true don't tell me let me
keep that one let me keep that one
lie to me baby
sweet little love so in this book are
there areas because I know in my book I
can point to specific chapters where I'm
like man I really wish people had paid
more attention to X yeah like maybe it
didn't quite get the emphasis so I can
own that responsibility but maybe they
for whatever reason didn't pay enough
attention to this one component yeah
is there something that comes to mind I
don't know yet because it hasn't come
out oh I know
what would I hurt you the most if people
missed so I think what would bother me
the most
is the the amount that Oprah and I
emphasize the role of unhappiness and
living a full life see that one of the
biggest mistakes that people make as we
talked about before is that people say I
want to be happy but and then they talk
about some source of unhappiness in
their life that they think blocks their
unhappiness and that's the wrong way of
thinking because you can get happier
even if you're unhappy absolutely 100
all day long because these are existing
in different parts of your brain number
one but number two
happiness is not the goal and
unhappiness is not the enemy getting
happier is the goal you know Oprah
coined this term in the book she said we
got to stop talking about happiness
because that's actually not the goal the
goal is happierness that's really what
we're going for is happiness and to get
happierness you need unhappiness in your
life look you need negative emotions to
keep you alive but you also need the
deferral of gratification to get your
satisfaction and you need to understand
the nature of the frustration that comes
such that you can start to manage your
wants you need like serious full-on
suffering to find the answers to the
questions of meaning that we talked
about you do my son needed boot camp you
and I need
substantial problems with mood to put it
euphemistically we need no look
we need sadness you know Freud's
greatest student Carl Jung
so much greater in so many ways so that
you don't really understand happiness
until you've experienced unhappiness
because of the contrast but more to the
point you've not been fully Alive
because unhappiness is what actually the
suffering is what helps you understand
what you're made of and what you could
bear and only then will you find the
answers to the why am I alive and for
what would I be willing to die questions
you don't find the meaning questions the
answers at that week at the beach in
Ibiza yeah
you find it
in the depths when somebody who loved
eyes when you're afraid of what your
future holds
when you feel hopeless
that's when those moments become real
and that suffering turns out to be an
integral part in your journey to
happiness so the number one thing that
Oprah and I will be very disappointed
about is that people don't actually
become more Fully Alive through the
Transcendent passage of both happierness
and and the unhappiness that is a a part
of what it means to be a real person
it is a
diverse and ever-changing tapestry that
is for sure it is and you know I think
about it one of the biggest mistakes
that I think that my students make by
the way right now if I were to go back
to 1968 or 1969 Woodstock you know and
the hippie said if it feels good do it I
remember my dad heard that for the first
time he's like that's the end of America
it's kind of right anyway
if we had a Woodstock today it might be
if it feels bad make it stop if I'm
suffering treat it
if there's pain it's evidence that I'm
defective that I'm broken something's
got to change that's wrong that's wrong
thinking look the Tim Ferriss I'm
talking to you right now had to suffer I
mean these messages that you're giving
are dramatically different than what you
were writing 15 and 20 years ago they're
dramatically different it doesn't mean
it was wrong 15 or 20 years ago but it
was incomplete it wasn't deep in the
same way and the depth actually comes
from the not just from the good it also
comes from the bad
this is you know Andrew Solomon who
wrote the Noonday demon have you read
that book no it's the best book I've
ever read about anxiety and depression
you know Andrew Solomon's a phenomenal
writer all right so what is the title
again
the Noonday demon which was an ancient
way of talking about depression which
comes over you like a Noonday demon it's
like the black dog it's like Winston
Churchill's black dog for sure the
Noonday demon it's an Incredible Book
it's a total page Turner for anybody
who's actually had anything value does
not sound like a pitch I know this is
phenomenal though it's so interesting
but it's just beautiful writing but in
the end he said in the sum and final
balance
I have to conclude that I love my
depression
because it's part of who I am as a
person and it's allowed me to learn what
my life is all about I don't wish it on
anybody I don't want it to come back but
it is who I am and so therefore I have
no choice but to love it I'm
paraphrasing but it's you know his words
are more beautiful than anything I could
remember
but it's really an important thing for
us to remember and anybody who's
watching you and who follows you and who
admires you and gets a lot of sustenance
from the knowledge that you bring to
this podcast what they have to realize
is that they are beneficiaries of Tim
ferriss's suffering
and if they want to lift up the world
they have to suffer too
it's Food For Thought yeah Food For
Thought may not be candy bars might be
high fiber but it is important food for
thought it's a philosophical Cliff bar
yeah yeah sorry people love those I
don't mean not to cast aspersions my
friends at Cliff you know
but I have thought about this very
deliberately and you know I don't wish
suffering upon anyone
but I had someone give me a very good
advice at one point and and
the words can be substituted of course
but she said to me after I had gone
through very gifted therapists and
with a lot of experience a lot of
mileage with different types of patients
including some very tragic and difficult
cases and she said
take your pain make it part of your
medicine
and I was like okay meaning the medicine
in my case the way I think of that is
what I can teach or provide or just the
perspective through which I can speak
and explore given that I have the
history that I have understand this is
what the best therapists do they teach
you about yourself they help you to
learn and grow from your pain and they
help you to treat yourself and serve
others yeah that's what the great
therapists do the worst therapist is
like yeah I'll help you take care of
that and we'll make that problem go away
no no no no no no no no no no no
I want to learn I want to grow
and I want to surf yeah
surf part has been a very critical to
the tether of meaning
that has given the suffering
meaning exactly meaning made it I don't
want to say irrelevant like
the greater the potency of the meaning
and the less the suffering
incapacitates you
well I ask you
is it possible you're not afraid to
suffer more
now because you said you know pleasure
and and you know as a defense et cetera
et cetera but I don't feel like I'm
sitting with somebody who's afraid of
suffering it's certainly less than it
was
I also think that they're just
pleasurable things that I really like
yeah
there's weird yeah yeah yeah how bizarre
there is that I remember reading about
one of your you know a sexual experience
in the you know in the the four-hour
body or is like to get more testosterone
and then I ate a single Brazil nut
yeah it was lots of Brazil nuts
cholesterol loading I did lots of crazy
stuff in the for our body but it was it
was somebody who knew how to have fun
yeah that chapter how old were you what
34 or something when you're on 30 yeah
early 30s yeah yeah yeah so anyway no I
respect the fact that you like to have
fun and you like to feel good I get that
but I don't sense fear from you yeah I
would also say what I have done is
I've built in to my life
a lot of
premeditated deliberate discomfort to
inoculate myself against the fear of
unpredictable discomfort and it's not a
cure-all but I have found that that's
exposure therapy it's exposure therapy
also just like wading into some of the
deep Waters psychologically
and psycho emotionally that I would be
prone to fearing
learning how to take swimming lessons in
some of those deep Waters I would say is
also an approach so
it resembles exposure therapy but
there's also a
skill development piece on top of that
which is combined with the exposure I
would say which I know is a bit nebulous
no no but it makes perfect sense and
there's actually a way that we can all
get better at that because I know a lot
of people are watching this like yeah
yeah how do I get better at that here's
one way to do that that actually is a
very practical way to do it start each
day with a statement of fact and then an
aspiration the statement of fact is I
don't know what's going to happen this
day I don't know I learned this from a
pediatric oncologist by the way somebody
who has you know has bad cancer
diagnoses to kids yeah he says he tells
the parents to every day start the day
saying
I don't know what's going to happen in
my future
but I do know I am alive this day and I
am deeply grateful for everything that
happens for good and for bad
it takes cajones man
it it's hard because you're like you
catch your a little bit right because
what's your what's your what Mother
Nature wants you to do is to look for
the good feelings and to avoid the bad
feelings because that's the evolutionary
imperative you know to avoid the disgust
and the anger and the sadness and the
grief and the loneliness and to avoid
those things not to embrace those things
to you know to say
it's inevitable bring it on but if you
can actually do that to steal yourself
to steal as they say in Isaiah I steal
my face like Flint
right and that's how to do it look I
don't know I don't know what's going to
happen today but I do want to know I'm
alive right now I'm not going to waste
this day and the way I don't waste this
day is by being grateful for every
single thing that happens good and bad
bring it on here we go
I have a the gift I received quite a
while ago but a actually
steal my face like Flint it is a piece
of I think it is steel and it's engraved
with a quote from I think it is Neil
Donald Walsh I may be getting that off
someone can fact check but the quote is
the struggle ends when the Gratitude
begins yeah and it's such good advice
yeah and you don't have to be grateful
only for
the Obviously good things no no no on
the contrary and that's really that's
what separates first course gratitude
from PhD level stuff
um and by the way here's a practical way
to do that
to be grateful for bad things a very
practical way to do it I ask my students
to make a failure Journal
and so what that is is every time a bad
thing happens something bad happens
frequently when you're 28 years old you
know somebody breaks your heart today
and tomorrow you're going to be on a
test and and the next day after that you
know you don't get the interview for
that job you hoped for and it's just a
constant string of disappointments and
thrills because it's like this is
when you're 28 years old okay so every
time something happens that really
frustrates and and disappoints you or
you screw up or whatever you take out
your failure journal and you're right in
your failure journal what happened and
then you leave two lines open behind it
and you put reminders on your phone ding
one month for me you gotta go back and
six months from now one month from now
you got to go back and say what you
learned from that thing that you would
forget otherwise and six months from now
you got to go back and say a good thing
that happened because of that thing and
there's always entries always always
always and so it's like
I went into my performance review and my
I thought I was doing a really good job
my my boss basically told me that I'm a
like a b player at best this happens
constantly right that bums me out I just
want to put it behind me I want to go
hang out with my friends and have a
couple of beers and complain about my
boss and move on right no no no no write
it on your failure Journal one month
from now remember it and go back
huh you know what I learned from that is
I thought I was going to be super bummed
about that for a long time and it
bothered me for like a week that's
interesting now that's homeostasis
there's a lot of brain science in that
six months later you come back and you
say
when I thought about that I realized
that that probably wasn't the perfect
fit for my career and I went on the
market
and I have a better job now I think that
the job I have now is a better fit and
every single thing that happens that you
put in your failure Journal you will
realize that there's something
generative that happens from this in
terms of learning and in terms of
gratitude and you will turn that thing
into something sooner or later when
something really bad happens to you
you'll be like oh God I get to put in
the failure Journal
it'll really change your perspective on
it because failure and disappointment
and frustration and sacrifice and pain
will take on their proper perspective
which is part of your full life
we shall see that's great we shall see
that's that's famous
[Music]
so true yeah well Arthur this has been
so much fun now the title of the book is
build the life you want the Art and
Science of getting happier and by the
time this comes up you will be able to
certainly find it yeah to purchase it
yeah for all fine books are sold and
also if people like
Oprah and I will read it to you
you mean I'm guessing uh in audiobook
form look no we'll come to your house
and with the dulcet tones of Oprah's
voice well you'll lull you to sleep no I
mean we read it yeah I know
yeah that's right sorry Oprah I kind of
committed us to this thing you know
let's just say to the booktubers taking
on New Dimensions but we know we read
the book for penguin random house and
and I'm really I'm really super happy
with the way that it turned out mostly
because
my voice is interspersed with her
beautiful voice one of the most famous
voices in America an incredible
experience congratulations thank you so
people can find the book where all fine
books are sold
I just love saying that yeah and is
there anything else you'd like to point
people to whether it's a social profile
or a request of the audience an Ask of
the audience something you'd like to
close with anything at all that you'd
like to add before we yeah I mean this
is really
a teaching experience both for me and
Oprah and just part of my life which is
dedicated to writing speaking and
teaching about love and happiness to
bring people together in bonds of love
using the science and ideas that's
really my mission statement for the rest
of my life and that really is a teaching
Mission just like yours as a teaching
Mission so there's a lot of stuff that
I'm doing ancillary to books and columns
Etc
have classes like video classes and
things that people can watch and my goal
in doing those things there's some all
on my website Arthur brooks.com but when
people do those things my goal is
training them to be happiness teachers
this is really what it's all about
because remember it's understand change
your habits share with others and so to
learn more about exactly how to do that
we we're developing a lot of resources
that make that possible in a I think a
pretty effective way and I would I would
love people to do that for the single
reason that I want a movement I want to
be part of a movement of people whose
hobby is
the science of happiness and bringing it
to others you know there's a lot of
people who are broken in this world and
who are sad and who are suffering and if
we had people who were warriors for
greater happiness for themselves through
others through real knowledge and a
commitment to change I'm truly convinced
that this is the one thing that I can do
that could have an impact on the world
that needs to be a lot happier Arthur
so glad that we were able to find the
time have this conversation and I admire
the work you do I respect the work you
do I value the work that you put out in
the world it does help people so I
wanted to
also just simply thank you for putting
out what you put out and spending time
on the things you spend time on likewise
Tim I've only met you today
in person but I feel like I've known you
for a long time because I've been
consuming your work like so many
millions of other people and you've
enriched my life a lot thank you for
that thanks man I really appreciate it
this has really sparked a lot in me I've
taken copious notes so I have
a number of things that I'll be focusing
on getting small Brothers K muscular
philosophies I just love the phrasing so
I wrote it down
Aristotle Aquinas all things that can
lead you to build the life that you want
and for everybody listening we will have
extensive show notes links to everything
as usual at tim.blog podcast and until
next time be just a bit Kinder than is
necessary to others and to yourself
thanks for tuning in